nach berlin über diese
danke anja chalet das ausgesprochen
charmant und wenn wir schon mal bei
zeiten sind dann können wir mal auch auf
andere zeiten noch mal gucken es sind
morgen 100 tage ampelkoalition und dann
stellt man nicht durch die frage wann
ist eine koalition schon mal unter
solchen bedingungen mit solchen
konflikten und mit solchen aufgaben in
ihre zeit gestartet die themen spiegeln
sich wider sie haben teilweise
angedeutet in ihrer moderation eben
schon wir haben das thema zwei jahre
corona und damit verbunden heute die
debatte über die impfpflicht erstmals im
parlament morgen dann die änderung im
infektionsschutzgesetz und das andere
ganz große thema klimawandel dass in den
nächsten jahren noch begleiten wird auch
das wird zumindest indirekt eine rolle
spielen wenn heute am frühen abend über
änderungen an der eeg umlage beraten
wird was dazu führen soll dass die
verbraucher weniger kosten haben dadurch
also diese kosten schon mal gesenkt
werden sollen und das große und zentrale
thema dieser tage ist natürlich der
krieg russlands gegen die ukraine mit
einer aktuellen stunde gestern mit einer
aktuellen stunde heute und auch das hat
man ja schon meine damen und herren eben
schon gesagt mit einer video schalte zu
ukraine präsident wolodimir see lenski
logischerweise ist das auch bei uns das
thema und ich freue mich dass heute
morgen bei uns sind sieben badeland die
obfrau der linksfraktion im auswärtigen
ausschuss und sprecherin für
internationale politik und abrüstung
guten morgen ihn und michael roth ist
bei uns aus der spd-fraktion vorsitzende
auch im auswärtigen ausschuss wir werden
ganz viel nach vorne gucken in diesem
gespräch so viel zeit wie wir haben aber
einen kleinen blick zurück würde ich
dann trotzdem noch machen wir haben drei
wochen jetzt krieg in der ukraine welche
entscheidung beziehungsweise
fehleinschätzungen aus den vergangenen
jahren ist in diesem zusammenhang aus
ihrer sicht herr roth die
schmerzhafteste sie waren auch acht
jahre staatsminister im auswärtigen amt
dass bei aller notwendigen
dialogbereitschaft gelegentlich die
wehrhaftigkeit und die stärke auf der
strecke geblieben ist wir haben immer
wieder gehofft dass ein autoritärer
herrscher wie putin auch bereit ist auf
gute vernünftige argumente einzugehen
und sich auch er dem frieden
verpflichtet fühlt aber wir hätten
sicherlich noch selbstbewusster und
stärker auftreten müssen um deutlich zu
machen
das eben eine verständigung die nichts
mit frieden und versöhnung zu tun hat
für uns inakzeptabel ist eine frau denn
die linke hatte eine besondere beziehung
zu russland auf eine besondere beziehung
zu bleiben putin die aufgabe welcher
selbstgewissheit war für sie in den
vergangenen 21 tagen die schmerzhafteste
musik korrigieren wir haben keine
beziehung zur russischen regierung wir
haben immer mit der opposition einen
kontakte pflegt mit den
oppositionsparteien
wir haben allerdings uns absolut geirrt
und getäuscht
wir dachten wir haben mit präsident
putin in russland einen präsidenten der
rational denkt der weiß dass ein krieg
in der ukraine vielleicht militärisch
für eine solche überlegene nuklearmacht
gewinnbar ist aber politisch ist sie auf
keinen fall zu gewinnen und wir haben
uns darin getäuscht wir dachten nicht
dass er tatsächlich zu einem solchen
krieg zu einem angriffskrieg der
völkerrechtswidrig ist der durch nichts
zu rechtfertigen ist fähig ist das war
eine täuschung da sind wir leider nicht
alleine trotzdem aber muss ich sagen es
ist nicht falsch gewesen was die
entspannungs politik von willy brandt
und egon bahr uns gebracht haben nämlich
die wiedervereinigung und vieles mehr
insofern würde ich davor warnen jetzt
alles auf dem müllhaufen der geschichte
zu werfen und zu denken das war alles
falsch ganz im gegenteil will ja auch
gar keiner also insofern herr roth die
rede von melodien medial ins kiki werden
die schaltung funktioniert technisch
waren wir jetzt mal entspannt ausgehen
auf die harte kritik an der
bundesregierung an deutschland und damit
auch an der koalition erwarten sich
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sind
weiter in einem ganz furchtbaren
angriffskrieg ausgesetzt und putin hat
keinen zweifel daran gelassen dass er
mit aller härte und brutalität weiter
zuschlagen wird insofern kann ich mir
schon vorstellen dass es eine klare
erwartungshaltung auch unsere
ukrainischen freundinnen und freunde
gibt noch mehr zu tun militärisch mehr
zu tun mehr zu tun bei der humanitären
hilfe und die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
bei ihrer mutigen und tapferen kampf
gegen diesen furchtbaren krieg zu
unterstützen
das vermuten viele beobachter dass selen
ski möglicherweise auch mehr
militärische unterstützung erwartet was
würden sie ihm sagen in diesem
zusammenhang wenn sie ihm direkt
gegenüberstehen würden womit der rechnen
kann aus deutschland und sollte nun wir
haben ja den auftritt von hansi lenski
gestern im us-kongress gesehen wo er
auch eine flugverbotszone der nato
gefordert hat ich halte es für richtig
dass bundeskanzler scholz diesen
wahnsinn zurückgewiesen hat und ich
hoffe dass das auch so bleibt eine
flugverbotszone der nato in der ukraine
gegen russland ist nichts anderes als
eine kriegserklärung an russland und
würde mit einem dritten weltkrieg
bringen und ich glaube jetzt ist
wirklich bei aller kritik die das
stattfindet also das leid was da jeden
tag passiert und dass menschen dort
sterben jeden tag müssen wir besonnen
sein dass der krieg nicht eskaliert zu
einem krieg zwischen nato und russland
weil das würde tatsächlich ein inferno
ein schlachtfeld europa bedeuten und das
kann niemand wollen ich verstehe dass
die republikaner vor allen dingen die
trump anhänger jetzt gerade diese
flugverbotszone wollen aber ich finde
deutschland muss hier vor allen dingen
in verantwortung der deutschen
bevölkerung in der bevölkerung in europa
alles unterlassen was in einem dritten
weltkrieg münden kann da sind sie
vermutlich meint zumindest einig oder na
ja der wahnsinn geht ja von den putin
aus und ich kann die forderung der
ukraine verstehen aber es gibt auch
innerhalb der nato darüber überhaupt gar
keinen konflikt wir sagen wir tun als
nato und als mitgliedstaaten für nato
und europäische union was wir können um
der ukraine auch beizustehen und dazu
gehört ausdrücklich auch eine
fortsetzung der militärischen
unterstützung aber wir wollen eben nicht
kriegspartei werden um nicht zum nicht
zu einer
wirklichen kriegspartei zu werden die
dann vielleicht auch einen dritten
weltkrieg mit zu verantworten hat aber
das muss man auch unseren ukrainischen
freundinnen und freunden gut erklären
weil ich natürlich schon auch verstehe
dass bei einem bomben haben mein
interesse daran hat dass die
militärischen aggressionen von moskau
ausgehen so gut es irgend geht auch
bekämpft werden damit sie sich schützen
und verteidigen können eine million
höher betroffenen lieferungen haben
natürlich die schlagkraft der
militärischen also der streitkräfte
ukraine erhöht und verstärkt aber ich
warne davor die illusion zu nähren dass
man gegen die überlegenheit der
russischen streitkräfte mit
waffenlieferungen tatsächlich beikommen
kann jeder weiß von militär die experten
sagen alle das wird keine wende
einleiten und dieser krieg wird nicht zu
gewinnen sein was wir jetzt machen
müssen ist sanktionen und
waffenlieferungen werden hier diesen
horror nicht stoppen was diesen horror
stoppen werden sind verhandlungen wir
brauchen verhandlungen wir müssen jetzt
alles tun um diese verhandlungen die ja
zahl kraft stattfinden sie zu
unterstützen beispielsweise auch dieses
treffen von selen ski und putin sollte
man wirklich tatkräftig unterstützen
dass das zustande kommt damit es einen
waffenstillstand
bekommt ukraine nur ein waffenstillstand
lädt das blutvergießen beenden keine
waffenlieferungen keine sanktionen die
aber ganz kurz mal zwischen gefragt und
so lange bis es solche gespräche gibt
würden sie alles laufen lassen wollen
oder geschliffen lassen man muss man
muss realistisch dass konsum zu einer
handlung bringen verstehen sie aber wie
ja wie wie jeder krieg auch kriege
werden durch verhandlungen beendet nicht
durch waffenlieferungen aber wenn eine
seite nicht verhandeln will was machen
sie würden wieso es wurde doch gesagt
sie wollen verhandeln beide seiten
silencio und politik haben gesagt sie
wollen verhandeln china israel und
andere sind dort schon am vermitteln und
das sollte man unterstützen ich möchte
wirklich davor warnen wenn man
verständlicherweise menschlich
verständlich sagt man möchte mit diesem
adresse nicht verhandeln dann muss man
aber auch sagen was man will und es gibt
keine alternative zu verhandlungen in
einem krieg aber es müssen ja zwei
seiten zu verhandlungen zustimmen jetzt
also verhandlungen und eine weitere
militärische unterstützung schließen
sich ja gar nicht aus sie bedingen
einander die ukraine hat nur eine chance
zu überleben und überhaupt auch putin zu
bewegen zu ernsthaften verhandlungen die
nicht wieder auf lügen und propaganda
beruhen wenn die ukraine stark ist
wehrhaft bleibt und ich höre dieses
argument ja seit drei wochen wir würden
den krieg verlängern also wenn es nach
putin gegangen wäre dann hätte er
innerhalb von 23 tagen die ukraine
überholt und einer marionettenregierung
eingesetzt aber es ist nicht zuletzt
auch der unterstützung des westens zu
verdanken dass die ukraine noch steht
und dass sie sich tapfer verteidigen
kann und wenn wir das lassen und wenn
wir die ukraine im regen stehen lassen
dann hat putin gewonnen weil er sonst
überhaupt kein interesse daran hätte
sich wirklich auch um ernsthafte
gespräche zu bemühen und es ist im
übrigen auch der ukrainischen seite hoch
anzurechnen dass sie sich immer wieder
an den verhandlungstisch gesetzt hat
gleichwohl putin eine totale
kapitulation eingefordert hat und die
waffen niemals geschwiegen haben
normalerweise ist es so wenn man solche
gespräche führt dann hat man einen
waffenstillstand zumindest zeitlich
befristet aber auch zudem war putin ja
nie bereit das bringt uns aber der
lösung des problems ja keinen schritt
weiter muss ich wirklich sagen jeder tag
an dem dieser krieg nicht gestoppt ist
ist ein tag wo menschen sterben und
hoher blutzoll bezahlt wird und deshalb
als ich meinen kann ja sein dass man
jetzt menschen beglückwünscht zum
heldentum aber ich möchte keine helden
ich möchte dass dieser krieg beendet
wird und dafür geht es nur mit
verhandlungen wissen sie militär das
haben viele gesagt immer militär gehen
kann ein land einmarschieren und das ist
ja jetzt hier passiert aber die politik
die diplomatie muss jetzt alles tun
damit das militär sich auch zurückziehen
da kommen irgendwie nicht so richtig
weiter an der stelle habe ich den
eindruck weil ich sie da auch
tatsächlich nicht verstehe weil dieser
krieg wird seitens russlands gegen die
ukraine geführt und nicht und das ist ja
kein wechselseitiges geschäft das der
stadt findet
der so das ist mal der eine
entscheidende punkt das heißt es könnte
im moment funktioniert doch nur appelle
wenn die eine seite im moment partout
nicht verhandeln will oder auch wie herr
roth eben auch schon ausgeführt hat so
harte vorgaben macht was man erreichen
will wo im moment überhaupt gar keine
verhandlungs potenziell da is a und b es
hat unzählige gespräche gegeben vor
diesem überfall vor dem 24 februar und
auch die haben zu nichts geführt also
das was sie einfordern einen dialog an
meinetwegen auch an diplomatie hat ja im
vorfeld stattgefunden es hat den
russischen präsidenten offensichtlich
nicht interessiert ist einfach wir haben
jetzt einen krieg was vorher war ist das
eine aber wenn man nach vorne das
problem auflösen möchte muss man doch
folgendes feststellen wie ist dieser
krieg zu beenden entweder durch
eskalation dass wir einen weltkrieg
haben ein inferno dort wo die nato mit
einsteigt was die ukrainische regierung
möchte dass die nato hier einsteigt oder
wir sagen folgendes und dann gibt es ja
wie gesagt signale es gibt doch die
erklärung von herrn präsident see lenski
wir wollen verhandeln es gibt die
erklärung von präsident putin wir sind
bereit zu verhandlungen und ich finde
was wir zu tun müssen und sagen so ihr
seid bereit dann bitte schön hier an den
tisch und sie zwingen zu diesen
verhandlungen weil anders können wir
diesen krieg nicht stoppen ich meine was
ist wirklich die alternative zu
verhandlungen gar nichts ist die
alternative alternative ist krieg zu
führen und das kann wirklich niemand
niemand der vernunft begabt ist kann
diese eskalation wohnen hier ich möchte
nicht dass europa zu einem nuklearen
schlachtfeld wird wo die nato mit in
diesen krieg gegen muslime ist gläubig
es geht auch gar nicht da wir haben doch
eine klare verabredung getroffen die
nato wird keine kriegspartei werden das
ist ja gar kein streitpunkt zwischen
ihrem ja es ist könnte es gibt eine
klare beschlussfassung der nato und eine
klare vereinbarung und von der sollten
wir ausgehen wir sollten jetzt nicht
irgendwelche nebenkriegsschauplätze
eröffnet aber im kern müssen wir doch
mal anerkennen dass putin sich erst
zaghaft bewegt hat als er gespürt hat
dass er auf massiven widerstand stößt
das heißt nur dann kann es eine
friedliche diplomatische lösung geben
wenn wir die ukraine nicht aufgeben und
diese sehr aggressiven
nicht hinnehmbaren forderungen von putin
gegenüber der ukraine sind ja jetzt erst
von putin leicht relativiert worden weil
er einsehen muss der krieg läuft nicht
so wie er sich das vorgestellt hat und
jeden tag da gebe ich ihnen recht
sterben ja nicht nur ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer sondern auch viele junge russin
die in diesen krieg geschickt werden und
die wahrscheinlich auch überhaupt nicht
wissen warum sie diesen krieg gegen
brüder und schwestern führen sollen denn
das war ja das narrativ das war ja das
narrativ von herrn putin aber wir dürfen
doch nicht wieder herrn putin auf den
leim gehen er hat auch gesagt was er
will er akzeptiert nicht die
territoriale integrität
der ukraine er will dass das land
preisgegeben wird und er will das land
im prinzip in die russische
einflusssphäre aufnehmen genauso wie er
das faktische mit belarus getan hat und
wenn wir jetzt nicht stehen dann wird
moldau oder irgendein anderes
osteuropäisches land das nächste land
sein was von putin unterdrückt wird was
wichtig ist es dass die keine selber
entscheiden sollte über seine zukunft
haben zu
ihrem referendum relativ leute ja und
jetzt hat michel rheinische führung
gesagt sie sind zu verhandlungen bereit
diese verhandlungen sollte man
unterstützen und nicht sagen das ist ein
no go das ist no go aus dem westen für
uns ist das bequem von hier zu sagen was
ein no go ist was wichtig ist das ist
dieser krieg gestoppt wird das leid der
menschen dort beendet wird und dafür ist
es wichtig verhandlungen jetzt zu führen
und ich wünsche mir dass der westen
diese verhandlungen unterstützt wir
könnten dieses gespräch locker noch eine
verbesserte weiterführen ob wir dann
furchtbar viel weiter weiß ich im moment
nicht wie er es hätte zumindest noch
jede menge punkte zugesprochen wie zu
sprechen gegeben was über die
beispielsweise den die wirkung von
sanktionen und manches mehr wird
sicherlich in der debatte wenn es dann
um die flüchtlinge geht am nachmittag
auch noch mal in der einen oder anderen
form aufkommen für jedenfalls für heute
morgen vielen dank unserer zeit ist um
danke frau da drinnen danke herr roth
dass sie heute morgen bei uns gewesen
sind dürfen jetzt auch sie müssen auch
sogar schon rein gehen denn das ist eine
besondere debatte die hier heute
stattfindet beziehungsweise ist gehörte
gar nicht zur debatte das ist ein
besonderer tagesordnungspunkt das
ukrainische präsident seelands die hier
live zugeschaltet wird um kurz nach neun
uhr im plenarsaal sie in katrin göring
eckardt und ich gebe mal ganz fix rein
so und dann sind wir im plenarsaal und
katrin göring-eckardt hat eben den
parlamentarierinnen und parlamentariern
mitgeteilt man warte noch einen kleinen
moment bis die verbindung steht in die
ukraine sie sehen auf den videowänden im
plenarsaal hinten da wird wo
normalerweise die rednerliste und die
tagesordnungspunkte
zu lesen sind da wird das bild dann zu
sehen sein mit der schaltung wir sehen
hier den
botschafter der ukraine in deutschland
andere manager noch kommunikation
betreibt möglicherweise mit denen die
auch mit für dieses schaltete dann
zuständig sind minister man gut gefüllt
das ganze plenum gut gefüllt hier im
bild jetzt gerade die minister habeck
und heil in gesprächen
20 minuten hat das parlament vorgesehen
für diese rede der ist der ukrainische
präsident natürlich frei falls er je
länger reden möchte zu den abgeordneten
im bundestag
es hat im vorfeld eine diskussion
gegeben die insbesondere seitens der
union
[Musik]
gefördert worden ist ob im anschluss an
diese rede an dieses schaltgespräch des
ukrainischen präsidenten es nicht
angesagt sei eine debatte zu führen zu
diesem thema das ist science der
koalition abgelehnt worden mit dem
verweis darauf dass das schlicht und
einfach nicht üblich ist dass im
anschluss an gastredner oder rednerin im
deutschen bundestag dazu noch debattiert
wird man hat in diesem zusammenhang
darauf verwiesen dass es ja bereits
gestern eine aktuelle stunde gegeben hat
zu dem thema wo sehr intensiv und
kontrovers debattiert worden ist und man
hat darauf verwiesen dass auch heute
der aktuelle stunde dann auf antrag der
unionsfraktion stattfinden wird in der
es gehen soll um die lage der
flüchtlinge die nach deutschland kommen
deren verteidigung verteilung auch da
gibt es ja durchaus diskussionen gab
dass alles so gut funktioniert wie es
funktionieren sollte die
bundesinnenministerium verweist darauf
dass es immer und täglich gespräche
zwischen bund und ländern über die
verteilung dieser flüchtlinge
nichtsdestotrotz
recht insbesondere berlin im moment noch
unter einer relativ großen last weil
viele die aus über polen beispielsweise
nach deutschland kommt natürlich
zunächst mal in
berlin ankommen und auch aufgrund der
nähe und aufgrund der vielen ukrainer
die in berlin leben eine community die
etwa 24.000 menschen umfasst so hat das
franziska giffey die regierende
bürgermeisterin neulich mal gesagt
natürlich auch versuchen hier erstmal
unter zu kommen weil es hier auch
natürlich kontaktnetzwerke gibt über die
man sich austauschen kann und außerdem
ist der weg zurück wenn er denn dann
wieder frei sein sollte der leichtere
von beispielsweise berlin aus andere
bundesländer wie beispielsweise
niedersachsen haben inzwischen
angeboten
hofer am messebahnhof drehkreuz
einzurichten das also flüchtlinge die
aus über polen nach deutschland kommen
egal jetzt diese züge gar nicht erst in
berlin ankommen sondern direkt weiter
fahren nach hannover und dann von
hannover aus die flüchtlinge
weitergeleitet werden ihnen andere
bundesländer in kommunen wo
aufnahmemöglichkeiten bestehen und wo es
platz gibt und auch eine infrastruktur
eine infrastruktur um ihnen zu helfen
so der grund für diese verzögerung die
wir hier haben bekomme ich eben
mitgeteilt ist ein einschlag ein angriff
welcher art auch immer bomben oder
raketen in der nähe des
präsidenten deswegen bestehe im moment
keine verbindung das könnte also sein
dass es hier rein technische gründe hat
dass diese verbindung im moment nicht
zustande kommt wir haben ein klein wenig
der dinge schauen neben dem plenarsaal
sehen den bundeskanzler im gespräch
und wir hören dass das bild jetzt
vorliegt wir hören im hintergrund auch
den gong und das bedeutet dass erstes
die sitzung jetzt offiziell auch
eröffnet wird durch bundestags
vizepräsidentin katrin göring eckardt
und dass es möglicherweise auch mit der
schalte zu wolodimir selensky klappt
jedenfalls ist der bundestag erkennbar
da entsprechend guter hoffnung
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen dem
siebten platz
ich grüße sie herzlich auch den
bundespräsidenten wulff
auch der tribüne und
werden heute morgen den kritischen
präsidenten wurde mir so wenn es gehe
hier gleichzuschalten können
er ist schon da slansky wir begrüßen sie
sehr herzlich
es ist uns eine ehre dass sie heute zu
uns sprechen werden auf der tribüne
begrüße ich auch und von herzen
botschafter andrej melik schön dass sie
erneut bei dem zimmer
seit jahren ist krieg die krim der don
was wurden überfallen und der neue
eiskalte brutale angriff auf die ukraine
auf die freiheit auf die demokratie
schafft ein leid dessen ausmaß wir hier
nur erahnen können seit drei wochen
leisten die menschen in der ukraine mit
allen kräften widerstand gegen putins
angriffskrieg dieser krieg muss beendet
werden russland muss seine angriffe
einstellen und seine truppen aus der
ukraine abziehen
die überwältigende mehrheit der
staatengemeinschaft hat diese forderung
an russland in der generalversammlung
der vereinten nationen bekräftigt den
angriffskrieg verurteilt mit entsetzen
sehen wir dass die russischen truppen
bewusst zivile ziele angreifen
das ist ein eklatanter verstoß gegen das
humanitäre völkerrecht
sie wieder
zivile angriffe das klingt technisch
aber das sind wohnhäuser krankenhäuser
schulen kindergärten es trifft
schutzlose menschen alte die in kellern
sitzen und nicht fliehen konnten weil
sie zu krank sind
schwangere jahr wöchnerinnen mit ihren
neugeborenen
wir sind tief berührt von dem mädchen
das offenbar in einem bunker singt ein
lied aus der eiskönigin wir sehen dich
amelia
menschen sind tot
der ukrainische biathletin film marley
schiff ist tot
die fußball-profis wie thalia kino und
mitri mal lenkung sind tot
reporterinnen lieber den krieg berichtet
haben sind tot ihre namen kennen wir
viele andere so viele andere kennen wir
nicht doch wir sehen euch wir sind in
gedanken bei euch und bei denen die um
euch trauern
die stadt mario pohl erlebt eine
katastrophe
auch interaktiv ersten an vielen vielen
anderen großen und kleinen orten besteht
eine dramatische notlage die menschen
brauchen hilfe schnell und ohne gefahr
vor neuen angriffen sie müssen
wenigstens die umkämpften orte auf
sicheren wegen verlassen können
millionen ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
sind geflohen tausende suchen jeden tag
zuflucht auch in unserem land viele
menschen in den nachbarländern der
ukraine und auch deutschland helfen wo
sie können sammeln spenden organisieren
hilfsleistungen kümmern sich um die
kriegsflüchtlinge sie spüren dass neben
menschlicher solidarität
eine entschlossene politik notwendig ist
putin hat mit seinem krieg auch unsere
friedensordnung angegriffen herr
präsident lieber wolle mit den ski
wir können sie sehen ihr land hat sich
für die demokratie entschieden und genau
das fürchtet sie mir putin er versucht
ihrem land eine eigene geschichte
identität
existenzrecht abzusprechen doch damit
ist er schon jetzt gescheitert
die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sind
geeinter und entschlossener als je zuvor
sie zeigen jeden tag wie stark der
freiheitswille ist
und ich sage das auch ganz persönlich
herr präsident
als jemand der in der ddr aufgewachsen
ist und teil der friedlichen revolution
war weiß ich dass freiheit ein geschenk
ist
und doch immer wieder erkämpft werden
muss
2004 durfte ich auf dem majdan sprechen
als hunderttausende für demokratie in
ihrem land demonstriert haben ein satz
der demonstrantinnen von damals hat sich
mir eingebrannt
rasen nass pater
nass netto lahti zusammen sind wir viele
wir sind nicht zu besiegen der weg den
die ukraine bestritten hat war nicht
leicht er war konsequent er war
demokratisch europäisch so wie auch ihre
wahl zum präsidenten dieses wunderbar
stolzen landes herr präsident lieber
wolle sie million ski die welt steht der
ukraine bei deutschland steht an ihrer
seite sie haben das wort
ich danke sehr verehrte frau präsidentin
göring eckardt sehr werden herr
bundeskanzler scholz sehr verehrte damen
und herren abgeordnete
gäste anwesend der journalisten
sehr verehrtes deutsches volk ich wende
mich an euch nach drei wochen der
unerwarteten angriffs der russischen
truppen in die ukraine nach acht jahren
krieg im osten unseres landes im bass
ich wende mich an euch als russland
bombardiert unsere städte und zerstört
alles was in der ukraine da ist das sind
wohnviertel krankenhäuser schulen
kirchen alles mit paketen mit luft
bomben mit atelier
in drei wochen sind
sehr viele ukraine gestorben tausende
die besatzer haben 108 kinder getötet
mitten in europa bei uns im jahre
ich wende mich alles sieht nach vielen
treffen verhandlungen erklärungen und
bitten nach den schritten zur
unterstützung die die die manche sind zu
spät gekommen sind und nach sanktionen
die vielleicht zu wenig sind um diesen
krieg zu stoppen und nachdem wir gesehen
haben
wie viel ihre unternehmen noch in
russland geblieben sind im land das euch
einfach ausnutzt und manche länder um
den krieg zu finanzieren
in drei wochen des krieges in für unser
leben für unser freiheit haben wir uns
überzeugt daran dass wir gespürt haben
und dass sie vielleicht nicht alle
merken aber
sie befinden sich irgendwie wieder
hinter der mauer nicht berliner mauer
aber mitten in europa wo gibt es
freiheit und dieses mauer ist stärker
mit jede bombe die auf unser wurden in
der ukraine
fällt bei jeder entscheidung die nicht
getroffen wird und den frieden obwohl es
uns helfen konnte wann ist das geschehen
sehr verehrter politiker sehr verehrtes
deutsches wohl warum ist das wirklich
wir haben immer gesagt dass no strings 2
ist eine waffe und vorbereitung auf den
großen krieg und wir haben als antwort
bekommen dass es wirtschaft wirtschaft
wirtschaft und das war ein cent für die
neue mauer wir haben euch gefragt was
soll ukraine tun um mitglied der nato zu
sein und die garantierte sicherheit zu
bekommen wir haben die antwort gehört es
gibt keine solche entscheidung bis jetzt
auf dem tisch und in der nächsten zeit
wird das nicht das war tritt er das war
traurig für uns an diesem tisch und auch
jetzt zögern sind bei dem beitritt der
ukraine der europäischen union wenn
offen gesagt für manche ist das die
politik und in wirklichkeit ist das ein
stein für eine neue mauer als wir
gebeten haben um präventive aktionen wir
wandten uns andere hob an kleine stadt
wir wandten uns an euch und
damit er größer spürte dass sie kraft
sind aber wir spielten die verzögerung
wir haben denn wir da stand verspürt wir
haben kapiert sie wollen die wirtschaft
wirtschaft wirtschaft weiter fortführen
und auch jetzt die
maschinen zwischen meinestadt.de
dieser stand
brachte zu uns den krieg und das wird
auch wieder eine mauer sein und sie
sehen nicht was sich hinter dieser mauer
versteckt das ist eine mauer zwischen
den menschen in europa und deswegen
verstehen nicht alle dass wir heute was
wir heute erleben ich wende mich an euch
im namen aller ukraine und ich wende
mich an euch aus mariupol die
einwohner der stadt die von russischen
truppen blockiert wurden und praxis dem
bürgen gleichmachen vernichten alles was
da ist alles und alle die da sind 100000
menschen
wochen jeden tag 24 stunden ohne wasser
ohne elektrizität ohne essen ohne
verbindung voi lang die russischen
truppen unterscheiden nicht zwischen den
zivilen
soldaten zwischen den zivilen objekten
und betrachten als zielscheibe alles
in der stadt wo
das schauspielhaus wo tausende von
menschen saßen das gestern gesprengt
wurde auch ein geburtshaus auch viele
andere zivil häuser die zerstören alles
den ganzen tag 24 stunden und sie lassen
keine humanitäre güter bei uns ist die
stadt blockiert
55 tage wird vom basiert damit keine
rettung für unsere menschen kommt das
können sie alles sehen wenn sie uns
unterstützung und wenn sie die mauer
etwas verschieben damit das ist also
eine luftbrücke könnte man machen damit
der himmel
sicher ist jetzt in unserem land wenn
wir können auch keine brücke keine
luftbrücke machen als die russischen
raketen und bomben die ich wende mich an
euch im namen der ukraine der eltern
ukraine die den krieg überlebt haben und
die auch vor 80 jahren auch die
besatzung erlebt hat die biene jahr geht
das ein baden
jahres besuchte uns im letzten jahr
präsident steinmeier und der verehrte
diese 30 diese tragödie und jetzt schlug
dort die russische rakete ein und das
ist in die ehemalige ruine landete
wieder eine rasche
also wieder nach 80 jahren ich wende
mich an
ich niemals wiederholen und es ist alles
wenn man das nichts verkörpert dann ist
das nicht wird und wieder versucht man
in europa das ganze volk zu vernichten
warum
worum im wesentlichen ich wende mich an
euch im namen unserer soldaten die
unsere werte verteidigt unser land und
auch die werte von denen wir oft
sprechen hier in europa hier in europa
hier menschen können frei leben und und
wir können unser menschen wollen frei
leben und nicht einem staat unterwerfen
dass unser land für das eigene heldt wir
können das nicht warum die staaten
hinter dem ozean es sind jetzt näher
stehen als ihr weil das die mauer ist
das ist die mauer
und wir merken diesem aber nicht aber
wir schlagen uns an dieser mauer solange
wir kämpfen darum das eigene volk zu
erhalten
politiker deutsches volk ich danke jedem
der uns unterstützt ich danke
einfachen menschen die aufrichtigsten
ukrainer bei euch helfen der
journalisten die ihre arbeit ehrlich
verden und zeigen das ganze böse was
russland zu uns gebracht hat und auch
dem deutschen dem deutschen business
geschäftsleute der die moral höher
stellte als die wirtschaft wirtschaft
wirtschaft wir danken der politiker die
als ich versuchen diese mauer zu brechen
die
di di di di di und
unterstützen die verstärkte sanktionen
und die kinder zu retten
kann direkt gerettet werden der frieden
in der ukraine der frieden in europa das
wir danken den menschen die nicht ca
russland von stift abzuschalten und die
verstehen das embargo notwendig ist dass
es notwendig ist dass die unterbindet
die dies in kriegs und ukraine wird in
der europäischen union sein ich bin
dankbar allen die alle wissen
dass sie das es gibt immer mehr
verantwortung und tapferkeit wenn es um
die rettung der menschen gehe es ist
fällt uns schwer
ohne unterstützung der welt zu leben
ohne eure hilfe ukraine und europa zu
verteidigen ohne dass das sie tun was
sie in der lage sind zu tun damit sie
sich nicht schämen nach diesem krieg
nach dem zerstörten zum zweiten mal nach
80 jahren nach der am boden zerstörten
stadt
80 jahren nachdem viele menschen getötet
und gefoltert wurde zum zweiten mal was
was ist wird die historische
verantwortung die immer noch nicht
gezeigt wurde und bereut wurde was vor
80 jahren geschah und das was jetzt
wieder die mauer und das wird immer eine
mauer seien die immer mehr verlangen
wird ich werde mich an euch und ich
erinnere mich an euch dass die das tun
ohne dass europa nicht überleben wird
und nicht ihre werte bewahren will
früherer
präsident der vereinigten staaten von
amerika rund regeln sagte einmal in
bayern
zerstört diese mauer und ich kann jetzt
sagen ich möchte euch sagen herr
bundeskanzler scholz zerstörung sie
diese mauer geben sie zeigen sie den
führer in deutschland in lieder der das
verdient und ihrer nachkommen werden nur
stolz auf sie sein unterstützen sie uns
unterstützen sie jeden ukraine
bitte helfen sie uns helfen sie uns
diese krieg zu stoppen
ich danke sehr
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich denke
ich sage im namen unseres gesamten
hauses herzlichen dank an diese
eindringlichen worte
der krieg muss aufhören und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass die parlamentspräsidentin
und parlamentspräsidenten der g7 staaten
und des europäischen parlaments ein
starkes zeichen des zusammenhalts in der
solidarität mit der ukraine gesetzt
haben wir haben uns gestern mit unserem
freund russland stefan tschök dem
parlamentspräsidenten der ukraine
ausgetauscht auch er hat sehr
eindrückliche worte eindringliche worte
an uns gerichtet in der sitzung in der
ich bärbel bas vertreten habe wurde eine
gemeinsame erklärung verabschiedet wir
betonen darin nachdrücklich die
souveränität der ukraine wir bekennen
dass wir seite an seite stehen mit der
ukrainischen wer uwe rada und mit ihren
frei gewählten abgeordneten unseren
kolleginnen und kollegen die wir von
hier aus
ausdrücklich grüßen die ihre arbeit im
parlament unter diesen bedingungen auch
weitermachen
das ukrainische volk und die
demokratisch gewählte regierung finden
unsere volle unterstützung sowie auch
die mutigen russinnen und russen die in
ihrem land für freie berichterstattung
sorgen und für ein ende des krieges
eintritten meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren die parlamente
der g7 bekennen sich zu ihrer
verantwortung menschen zu helfen die vor
dem krieg aus der ukraine fliehen und
sie aufzunehmen und den staaten
beizustehen die als nachbarländer eine
besondere humanitäre aufgabe zu erfüllen
haben gestern haben wir hier bereits
darüber debattiert werden dass heute
noch einmal tun über republik moldau
aber eben auch über unseren nachbarland
polen deswegen freue ich mich dass auf
der tribüne auch platz genommen hat der
stellvertretende außenminister der
republik polen herr minister schikowski
basic
ihr land leistet rotes in diesen tagen
und wir haben enormen respekt davor
meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren mir bleibt nur
und wenig ich bitte sie herzlich dass
ihrem präsidenten noch einmal
auszurichten 10 uhr am herzlichen dank
und slava ukraine
meine damen und herren nachdem wir
gestern bereits eine reihe von debatten
hatten will ich die sitzung des heutigen
tages unsere parlamentssitzung hier
eröffnen
[Musik]
vor eintritt in die tagesordnung
gratuliere ich dem kollegen christian
görke und dem kollegen dr weingarten zu
ihren sechzigsten geburtstag
ich wünsche ihnen alles gute
wir haben einige wahlen durchzuführen
darum bitte ich sie jetzt um
aufmerksamkeit auf vorschlag der
fraktionen der spd soll der kollege dirk
wiese als nachfolger für die kolleginnen
verena huber als ordentliches mitglied
des gemeinsamen ausschusses nach artikel
53 des grundgesetzes gewählt werden als
nachfolgerin für die kollegin sonder
eichwede soll das stellvertretende
mitglied der kollegin verena hubbards
gewählt werden
darüber besteht einvernehmen das scheint
mir der fall zu sein dann ist das so
dann sind ja kollege dirk wiese als
ordentliches mitglied und die
kolleginnen verena huber als
stellvertretendes mitglied gewählt
auf vorschlag der afg soll als
nachfolger für den kollegen gerold otte
der kollege joachim wundrak als
ordentliches mitglied des gemeinsamen
ausschusses gewählt werden außerdem soll
der kollege und könig als nachfolger für
den kollegen stefan brandner als
stellvertretendes mitglied gewählt
werden auch dazu sich kein widerspruch
dann ist die wahl der beiden bestätigt
weiterhin liegen vorschläge vor welche
kolleginnen und kollegen in den
stiftungsrat des des deutschen der
deutschen härtefall stiftung entsandt
werden auf vorschlag der fraktionen der
spd sollen johannes arlt und falko
droßmann gewählt werden auf vorschlag
der fraktionen der union thomas endl und
kerstin vierecke und auch vorschlag der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen merkels
perleberg auf vorschlag der fraktion der
fdp alexander müller und auch vorschlag
der fraktion der afc thema friedhof und
der vorschlag der fraktion die linke ali
al dine mal
damit sind sie auch alle einverstanden
dann sind die genannten kolleginnen und
kollegen gewählt
als vertreterin des verwaltungsrates im
präsidium der filmförderanstalt soll auf
vorschlag der fraktion der spd die
kollegin michelle müntefering benannt
werden auch dazu sehe ich keinen
widerspruch dann ist es so beschlossen
für den stiftungsrat der stiftung haus
der kleinen forscher soll auf vorschlag
der fraktion der spd die kollegin dr die
priester als nachfolgerin für den
kollegen dr karim rihawi gewählt werden
die fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
schlägt tochter anna christmann vor auch
dazu keinen widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
gemäß § 93 b absatz 8 unserer
geschäftsordnung sind auch vorschlag der
fraktionen deutsche mitglieder des
europäischen parlaments zu berufen die
an den sitzungen des ausschusses für die
angelegenheiten der europäischen union
teilnehmen können und dabei unter
anderem befugt sind auskünfte zu
erteilen und stellungnahmen abzugeben
anzahl und verteilungen müssen nach
wahlen zum europaparlament oder den
deutschen bundestag neu festgelegt
werden die fraktionen haben sich
insgesamt 19 auf 19 mitwirkungs
berechtigte mitglieder verständigt davon
entfallen auf die cdu/csu sechs auch
bündnis 90 die grünen 5 auf die spd vier
auf die afg zwei mitglieder die fdp und
die linke haben jeweils ein mitglied
damit sind sie einverstanden ich sehe
keinen widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
wir kommen zur tagesordnung die
tagesordnungspunkte 10 buchstabe a und
buchstabe c sowie der zusatzpunkt 16
werden abgesetzt der antrag der fraktion
der afg auch drucksache 20 10 20 soll
bei deren ohne debatte punkten
aufgerufen werden dazu sehe ich keinen
widerspruch dann ist das so beschlossen
bevor ich den ersten tagesordnungspunkt
aufrufe müssen wir noch einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
behandeln die fraktion der cdu/csu hat
beantragt die heutige tagesordnung um
eine debatte zum völkerrechtswidrigen
russischen angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
zu erweitern
dieser soll
dieser soll als erster
tagesordnungspunkt mit einer zeit von 68
minuten vorgesehen wären dann ist dazu
das wort gewünscht
märz kritischer
auch präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren seit drei wochen
beschweren uns diese schrecklichen
bilder aus der ukraine
und heute morgen haben wir eine rede des
chronischen staatspräsidenten gehört
wir haben zu beginn dieser woche die
mehrheitsfraktionen dieses hauses
gebeten im anschluss an diese rede eine
aussprache im deutschen bundestag zu
ermöglichen über den stand dieses
schrecklichen krieges
sie haben das mit ihrer mehrheit
abgelehnt der bundeskanzler sie haben
vor drei wochen an dieser stelle vor
knapp drei wochen eine eindrucksvolle
regierungserklärung abgeben
es hat in der zwischenzeit einen
sondergipfel der staats und
regierungschefs der europäischen union
gegeben es gibt in wenigen tagen einen
sondergipfel der staats und
regierungschefs der nato
und nach dieser rede heute morgen von
staatspräsident selensky wäre es doch
jetzt genau zu dieser minute der
richtige zeitpunkt einmal eine
zwischenbilanz zu ziehen die frage zu
stellen wo stehen wir haben wir das
richtig gemacht gibt es möglicherweise
entscheidungen die nach korrigiert
werden müssen stehen wir eigentlich
heute als bundesrepublik deutschland an
der richtigen stelle wenn es um diesen
punkten
sie haben
sie haben gestern in der debatte die wir
hier gehabt haben über eine stunde
schweigend auf der regierungsbank es ist
heute nachmittag führen wir eine
diskussion über die menschenrechtslage
in der ukraine und frau präsidentin mit
verlaub sie sagen uns heute morgen wie
der beirat der kleinen forscher gesetzt
werden soll
meine damen und herren wann denn wenn
nicht jetzt eine diskussion eine
zwischenbilanz eine frage an uns selbst
ob wir nicht
vielleicht ist und wenn es nur darum
geht uns noch einmal selbst zu
vergewissern wo wir stehen unter
bundeskanzler ich finde dass die
bundesrepublik deutschland anspruch
darauf hat von bienen heute morgen zu
erfahren wie sie die lage sehen und
welche schlussfolgerungen daraus zu
ziehen haben wenn sie allerdings spd
grüne und fdp mit ihrer meinung hier
eine mehrheitsentscheidung durchsetzen
dann will ich ihm von unserer seite aus
nur sagen dies stößt ausdrücklich auf
unseren widerspruch und unsere
missbilligung wir sind damit nicht
einverstanden wie sie das heute morgen
gehen
hat ja was redet für die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsident sind meine
sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen
präsident selensky
hat gerade eben eine sehr eindringliche
rede gehalten
dafür
insider
dafür danke ich ihm ausdrücklich
wir die ampelkoalition
sind überzeugt dass die worte des
ukrainischen präsidenten für sich stehen
sie haben es verdient für sich
wahrgenommen zu werden
die menschen in der ukraine
leiden seit dem 24
februar unser schrecklicher kriegsgewalt
durch putins truppen sie kämpfen sie
leiten sie haben angst
sie fliehen
familien werden auseinandergerissen und
menschen sterben täglich und fallen in
diesem völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
mit diesem völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
auf die ukraine hat der russische
präsident
grundlegende
internationale normen und werte mit
füßen getreten
deswegen hat der bundeskanzler
unmittelbar darum gebeten am sonntag den
februar vor dem deutschen bundestag eine
regierungserklärung
abzugeben er hat diese zeitenwende
umfassend erläutert und antworten darauf
gegeben
im anschluss hat es hier im deutschen
bundestag eine sehr lange ausführliche
aussprache gegeben das war angemessen
noch keine 24 stunden her hat cdu und
csu der tagesordnung für diese
sitzungswoche hier im bundestag
[Applaus]
und bisher
ungefähr fünf stunden später ohne neue
sachlage macht die union eine rolle
rückwärts und beantragte erweiterung der
tagesordnung jetzt müssen wir die
debatte weiterführen
während menschen in der ukraine sterben
sind wir gefordert wir sind gefordert
alles zu tun
ihre lage zu verbessern und die
flüchtlinge gut bei uns aufzunehmen
darum geht es in dieser situation
und daran arbeitet die gesamte
bundesregierung und die gesamte
koalition in dieser situation mit
unserem bundeskanzler oder
die
frau kollegin sie müssen bis zum schluss
vorne zum schluss die bundes
außenministerin annalena baerbock artist
gestern wie ich finde sehr treffend
gesagt in dieser lage ist zu hören eine
echte stärke zu hören und das wort
stehen lassen ich finde das ist ein
würdiger rahmen für diese rede die
ampelfrau kollegin werden diesen antrag
daher ablehnen
die förderung der unions fraktion und
ihres vorsitzenden friedrich merz auf
eine
debatte zur lage in der ukraine
jetzt noch ihren korte erster parlament
erster parlamentarischer geschäftsführer
der linksfraktion zum selben thema frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich muss jetzt zunächst einmal
feststellen dass sich die empörung der
ampelkoalition dem wunsch in dieser
situation eine debatte zu führen und zu
hören was die bundesregierung zu sagen
hat absolut lächerlich und genuss sind
macht das war viele sachen das war eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte aber
absolut deplatziert und
ich möchte schon feststellen so leid es
mir tut dass meine fraktion in diesem
fall den antrag der cdu csu ausdrücklich
unterstützt findet das mindeste dass wir
heute ihre positionierung auch zu den
fragen die eben der ukrainische
präsident hier aufgerufen hat dass sie
die hier daten und die sind ja
ich kann ja sehen dass also die
bundesregierung in ihrer ganzen pracht
wenn man so will hier heute versammelt
ist und da sie ja auch professionelle
politik machen kann ich erwarten dass
jetzt die gleich ans pult gehen und die
hier spontan diese debatte führen können
das wird möglich sein in diesen fragen
ich möchte zum zweiten mehr warum ich
das wirklich für völlig richtig halte
dass wir darüber diskutieren und katja
mast wir hatten eine debatte unter den
parlamentarischen geschäftsführern über
die tagesordnung sehr wohl und es gab
dem antrag des kollegen frei hier diese
debatte zu führen die form einer
fraktion ausdrücklich unterstützt worden
ist so ist die sachlage gegeben der
schritt mit kritischer fiel sein und so
hast du dir das nicht und was ich auch
schon kollege mir handels hat hier auch
schon sehr interessant finde also
ausgerechnet die fraktion fahren fdp und
grüne sie und wir waren ja noch vor 150
tagen in einer anderen situation wo sie
grundsätzlich mit uns dafür gestritten
haben dass die bundesregierung hier
rechenschaft ablegen solchen fragen und
das ist auf einmal vorbei das ist
verlogen
letzter punkt
letzter punkt den ich ansprechen möchte
ist sie kriegen das doch nun mit man
muss seinen kindern erklären dass wir
auf einmal wieder krieg in europa die
leute sprechen darüber es gibt große
angst und wir sind eine situation wo sie
herr bundeskanzler das größte
militarisierung und auf rüstungsprogramm
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland angekündigt haben so ist es
gewesen wovon ihre fraktion bis auf die
erste reihe nicht mal was wusste das ist
das mindeste dass wir darüber
diskutieren die ihre pläne dazu sind
sowohl das mindeste mal 100 milliarden
euro sondern müssen sich mit
und abschließend tage ich als christ und
auch wirklich kein zacken aus der krone
wenn wir jetzt hier diese debatte führen
und ich finde ich schon sagen also auch
diese sicherlich empörung wird dass die
oppositionsfraktionen einen antrag
stellt wirklich lächerlich da will ich
nochmal eins sagen sie müssen aufpassen
dass sie nicht nach 100 tagen schon so
arrogant sind wie andere nach 16 jahren
um das auch immer alles live
[Applaus]
zu wort gemeldet hat sich jetzt noch die
kollegin britta haßelmann für bündnis 90
die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
finde es sehr bedauerlich dass dem
parlament heute morgen nicht gelungen
ist in gänze
die rede des präsidenten der ukraine
einfach auf sich wirken zu lassen
[Applaus]
und in der parlamentarischen debatte
so
haben sie jetzt genug geschrieben da
hinten kommen sie doch nach vorne
meine damen und herren nicht fangen noch
mal an den offenbar hat der vorsitzende
der cdu/csu-fraktion
diese situation genutzt um seiner
fraktion so richtig einzuheizen
dass man wollte aus der lage was machen
muss ich habe deshalb gesagt ich
bedauere es dass das parlament nicht die
kraft gefunden hat der rede des
präsidenten
der ukraine mit würde und muss mit
respekt einfach zuzuhören und die
debatten und die debatten
sowie gemeinsam mit ihrer fraktion
vereinbart gestern mittag als das
parlament hier seine sitzung begonnen
hat hat er märz herr freiherr dobrindt
ich kann sie jetzt alle aufzählen haben
der tagesordnung die wir vereinbart
haben gestern eine debatte zu führen zur
lage des angriffskriegs putin auf die
ukraine und heute eine weitere debatte
zu führen zugestimmt es ist so sie haben
gestern der tagesordnung zugestimmt und
vorbereit
zur wahrheit gehört auf
und zur wahrheit gehört auch und das ist
eigentlich der situation unangemessen
ich habe lange überlegt ob wir für die
fraktion überhaupt hier reden weil wir
es einfach unmöglich finden was die
cdu/csu aus dieser situation macht meine
damen und herren
bis zum beginn der sitzung dieser
sitzung jetzt bis zum beginn der
würdigen rede die wir alle respektvoll
aufgenommen haben des präsidenten der
ukraine war die cdu/csu nicht in der
lage uns zu sagen
ob sie eine geschäftsordnungsdebatte
wünscht oder nicht das wohl man sich
offen halten meine damen und herren das
können im parlament so machen ja aber da
sieht man doch was hier gebucht wird
nicht die debatte in der sache sondern
die nehrung und erklärt
wenn er es wünscht sich dass sie nicht
in der lage sind die auseinandersetzung
in der sache zu suchen wenn ihr heute
wenn wir heute zudem mit ihnen
vereinbarten zeit darüber sprechen denn
das werden wir später
sie müssten bitteschön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herr baumann hat sich gemeldet und herr
dürr hat sich gemeldet ich gebe herrn
baumann das wort und dann herrn
bernd baumann erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer der fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir haben jetzt die bewegenden worte des
ukrainischen präsidenten gehört und was
macht dieses parlament heraus die cdu
hat der tagesordnung zugestimmt jetzt
auf einmal will sie ablehnen wenn sie
wirklich konsistent das verfolgt hätten
hätten sie der tagesordnung nicht
zustimmen dürfen sie haben ja ein
klamauk draus gemacht dass der sache
völlig unangemessen herr merz
ansonsten haben wir hier tag für tag und
sitzungswoche für sitzungswoche themen
die wichtig sind die wichtiger sind aber
heute haben wir ein thema da geht es um
krieg und frieden in diesem haus und
wenn wir dann einen staatspräsidenten
haben aus einem landtags angegriffen
worden ist und wenn die bekundung in
alle richtungen sind wie bewegend sei
und wie mitnimmt und wie wichtig da
unsere reaktion darauf ist oder machen
wir gar nichts machen jetzt impfschutz
gesetz und also das kann auch nicht sein
meine damen und herren wir wissen die
debatte wenigstens aufsetzen und der
bundeskanzler muss sich hier zu wort
melden und sagen wo es lang gehen soll
in reaktion auf die präsidentin das
verlangt der respekt
christian dürr für die fdp-fraktion
und ist gern durch ist der vorsitzende
der fdp-fraktion und dürfte dann der
letzte redner in dieser
geschäftsordnungsdebatte sein frau
präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kollegen und kollegen ich könnte jetzt
sagen herr kollege merz dass der
deutsche bundestag anders als sie es
gerade dargestellt hat in dieser woche
selbstverständlich mehrfach über den
furchtbaren angriffskrieg in der ukraine
sprechen wird und nicht nur der deutsche
bundestag im plenum in seinen
ausschüssen und wir als demokraten auch
in der öffentlichkeit ich könnte an
dieser stelle anführen herr kollege merz
dass das britische unterhaus und der us
amerikanische kongress danach keine
parteipolitische aussprache geführt hat
über die rede des präsidenten
und
könnte herr kollege merz sie noch einmal
betonen dass was die kolleginnen
kollegen hasselmann und
maas bereits gesagt haben
ich könnte an dieser stelle aus führen
dass in kenntnis der rede des
präsidenten der ukraine heute morgen
ihre fraktion gestern dieser
tagesordnung zugestimmt haben herr merz
ich könnte unterstreichen
dass sie all das wussten vor dieser
debatte sie wussten ist gestern morgen
sie wussten es gestern nachmittag herr
merz die kronzeugen die gerade für sie
hier gesprochen haben das spricht bände
aus meiner sicht ich teile einer
auffassung herr merz ja wir hätten
sicherlich und das hätte ihre fraktion
beantragen können eine unterbrechung der
sitzung machen können bevor wir in die
reguläre tagesordnung einsteigen aber
herr merz das was sie gerade gemacht
haben gerade vor dem hintergrund der
einigkeit der demokraten in diesem haus
was diesen angriffskrieg betrifft liebe
kollegen kollegen vor diesem hintergrund
herr merz war das ein unwürdiges
schauspiel was ihre fraktion heute
morgen auftritt ein unwürdiges
schauspiel
[Applaus]
herr kollege merz was die bewertung
dieses angriffskrieges betrifft sind
unsere fraktionen die fraktion der ampel
koalition ihre fraktion in wahrheit
nicht auseinander umso mehr umso mehr
herr kollege merz fordere ich sie auf
weil wir werden diese debatten
mutmaßlich leider in den kommenden tagen
und wochen öfter haben fordere ich sie
auf solche parteipolitischen spielchen
zu unterlassen das macht keinen sinn
herr merz es schadet den gemeinsamen
angeblich dann geben
meine aufgabe ist es jetzt zur
abstimmung zu kommen und ich will dazu
etwas erklären was in unserer
geschäftsordnung dazu vorgesehen ist es
ist richtig dass wir gestern die
tagesordnung für drei tage festgelegt
haben gleichwohl es ist das recht
einzelner fraktionen wie tagesordnung
ändern zu wollen das ist auch
rechtzeitig eingereicht und geschehen
zweiten
zweitens unserer geschäftsordnung sieht
nach paragraf 126 der geschäftsordnung
des bundestages vor dass eine solche
beschlussfassung ohne vorlagen mit zwei
drittel mehrheit im deutschen bundestag
gefasst werden müsste darauf weise ich
sie hin wenn ich jetzt zur abstimmung
komme und frage sie wer stimmt für den
aussetzungsantrag
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
herzlichen dank damit ist dem
aussetzungsantrag nicht mit der
notwendigen mehrheit zugestimmt
zugestimmt haben die fraktionen der
union die fdp und die linke dagegen
gestimmt haben die fraktionen von spd
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
ich rufe jetzt auf die tagesordnung
smolle lag mal darüber streiten ob eine
debatte nach der seele ins gerede
richtig ist oder nicht aber diese
debatte wie sich jetzt eben erlebt haben
und auch der tonfall in dem sie
teilweise stattgefunden hat den halte
ich jetzt mal gerade für so gar nicht
angemessen eine ein streit um eine
debatte während in der ukraine menschen
sterben wo es eigentlich ein großes
gemeinsames interesse gibt oder eine
gemeinsame position aller
fraktionen hier im deutschen bundestag
dass dieser krieg möglichst bald beendet
werden muss eine solche debatte über
eine über einer debatte die hätte man im
vorfeld lösen müssen finde ich
jedenfalls so und jetzt sind wir bei dem
tagesordnungspunkt angekommen der
eigentlich schon vor mindestens einer
guten halben stunde vorgesehen war es
geht um das thema impfpflicht auch diese
debatte haben sie ja mit sicherheit in
den kommenden monaten intensiv verfolgt
es geht um gesetzentwürfe mit
unterschiedlichen vorschlägen was eine
impfpflicht angeht es geht um anträge
aus
fraktionen aber auch noch mal um einen
gruppenantrag beispielsweise um den
fdp-politiker kubicki die eine
impfpflicht generell ablehnen dann gibt
es die gruppen anträge aus verschiedenen
fraktionen die eine impfpflicht ab 18
vorsehen es gibt eine variante wo es
zunächst eine beratung geben soll und an
eine impfpflicht wenn diese beratung und
die impfquote sind nicht erfüllt
im pflicht auch beispielsweise 50 jahren
also verschiedene liegen auf dem tisch
eine deutliche nötige mehrheit hat
bislang keiner dieser da setzen wir sind
regen anträgen haben und dass deswegen
die reedereien folge und die redezeiten
anders festgelegt worden sind als
üblicherweise das führt auch dazu dass
wir beim aufruf der rednerinnen und
redner nicht die fraktionen mit benennen
sondern gegebenenfalls die gruppen oder
eben die fraktion wenn es sich um einen
fraktionsantrag handelt die erste
rednerin ist heike behrens von der
gruppe behrends und anderen
das war nochmal erläuterungen von
bundestags vizepräsidentin katrin göring
eckardt die werden wir übrigens heute
öfter sehen genauso wie petra pau den
die beiden müssen sich aus verschiedenen
gründen die sitzungsleitung heute morgen
und ja heute und morgen durchweg teilen
also immer zwei stunden schichten und
jetzt heike behrens die für den antrag
generelle impfpflicht ab 18 spricht
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen stellen sie sich vor wir hätten
heute bereits eine impfquote von 90
prozent dann stecken wir nicht fest in
der größten infektionswelle seit beginn
der pandemie
deutschland hat
deutschland hat europaweit die höchste
instanz einzelne krankenhäuser müssen
wieder operationen verschieben höchste
anspannung und belastung für das
personal was für ein trauerspiel
wieder und wieder müssen wir erkennen
das virus ist nicht berechenbar es
reicht eben nicht aus nur auf die
aktuelle situation zu reagieren wir
müssen grundlegend die voraussetzung
dafür schaffen dass wir nicht noch
einmal von einer weiteren
infektionswelle überrollt werden und
darum setze ich mich gemeinsam mit
236 kolleginnen und kollegen aus vier
fraktionen für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht für alle
erwachsenen in deutschland ein
wir wollen unsere gesellschaft und unser
gesundheitswesen vor überlastung
schützen
dazu müssen wir eine hohe
grundimmunisierung aufbauen und wir
wissen seit langem und können dies in
anderen ländern sehen je mehr menschen
durch impfung
vor einer corona infektion geschützt
sind umso weniger menschen erkrankten
schwer umso schneller können wir zu
einem gesellschaftlichen leben ohne
freiheitseinschränkende schutzmaßnahmen
zurückkehren danach sehnen wir uns alle
und das ist dringend nötig für unsere
kinder und jugendlichen für unsere
wirtschaft für alle die tag und nacht um
das leben von schwer erkrankten menschen
ringen und auch sich um pflegebedürftige
kümmern
und vor die welle zu kommen müssen wir
eine hohe impfrate bis zum herbst
erreicht haben durch information
aufklärung beratung und eben auch eine
impf nachweislich die auch kontrolliert
wird unser gesetzentwurf ist gut
begründet und solider ausgestaltet mit
ihm werben wir hier und heute dafür
gemeinsam diesen echten weg der vorsorge
zu beschreiten ich wende mich an alle
verantwortungsbewussten
demokratinnen und demokraten im
deutschen bundestag an die
nachdenklichen und die unentschlossenen
an die denen es wichtig ist die
impfskepsis noch besser zu beraten zu
informieren und zu überzeugen
andy die ernsthaft für den herbst
vorsorgen wollen weil sie das gemeinwohl
im blick haben lassen sie uns gemeinsam
den konsens suchen für einen
nachhaltigen weg diese pandemie unter
kontrolle zu bringen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union
wenn sie ihren antrag zur impfpflicht
vorsorge nicht heute sondern vor vier
monaten eingebracht hätten dann müssten
sie heute im angesicht der aktuellen
dramatischen
informationslage zu der erkenntnis
kommen es braucht den
mechanismus wie sie es nennen jetzt
denn nur dann werden diejenigen die
heute noch nicht geimpft sind die
notwendige grund immunität bis zum
herbst erreicht haben und darum bitte
warten sie nicht länger ab sehen sie der
realität ins auge gehen sie mit uns den
weg der vernunft und der vorsorge die
unserem gemeinwohl dienen vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
heike behrens für die gruppe derer die
eine impfpflicht 18 befürworten und
dafür um unterstützung werben nächster
redner ist der müller
unionsfraktionsvize die union legte
einen eigenen antrag vor quasi an
vorsorge beschluss wenn eine bestimmte
quote nicht erreicht ist und eine
bestimmte lage eingetreten dann solle
man erst über eine image nicht reden
können wie in zug
stehen noch alle unter dem tiefen
eindruck der heutigen rede des
staatspräsidenten selensky aus der
ukraine und er sprach von einer mauer
und liebe ampel parteien anscheinend
haben sie eine mauer in dem kopf wenn
wir eine debatte nach dieser rede über
die impfpflicht in deutschland im
bundestag führen das geht gar nicht
menschen sterben
bomben fliegen auf theater wo kinder
schutz suchen und wir führen in diesem
haus eine debatte zur impfpflicht
und wenn wir den bundeskanzler sehen der
gott sei dank heute da ist dann wäre das
das mindeste gewesen herr bundeskanzler
dass sie dazu eine regierungserklärung
abgeben
ohne anstand ohne würde und ohne respekt
dem staatspräsidenten gegenüber sein
gesagt es stehen zu lassen ohne eine
antwort zu geben das ist diesem
parlament geschätzte frau präsidentin
unwürdig und
[Applaus]
wenn wir uns die
situation in der ukraine anschauen
dann ist das nicht nur bedrückend
sondern dann ist diese situation für uns
alle auch schwer in worte zu fassen
und deswegen ist das vielleicht auch die
sprachlosigkeit der ampel weil sie in
vielen punkten keine mehrheit haben ein
kollege sprach das an wie wird in die
ausgestaltung des sondervermögens 100
milliarden euro aussehen wie ist denn
ihre meinung und die kollegen von den
grünen sprach von parteipolitik wenn ich
die grüne jugend aus berlin in sozialen
medien leser die sagen für 100
milliarden euro könnte man 20 milliarden
hamster kaufen dann ist das unwürdig
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren und
parteipolitik und
schauen wir uns dann auch diese ampel an
dann hat sie nicht nur weil diesen
großen staatspolitischen
herausforderungen keine mehrheit sondern
auch bei der debatte die der
bundeskanzler gewünscht hat nämlich beim
thema impfpflicht man muss doch ganz
deutlich sagen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
ist die impfpflicht es gibt keine
mehrheit in diesem haus für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 und wir als
unionsfraktion die während der
orientierungs debatte
vom professor lauterbach als
gesundheitsminister per tweet beschimpft
wurde während unserer redner hier vorne
standen dass wir das parteipolitisch
ausschlachten würden wir haben uns
gedanken gemacht mit expertinnen und
experten gesprochen und einen vorschlag
gemacht der und nicht wie ihre
vorschläge dieses parlament trend meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren
und wir haben mit 197 abgeordneten einen
antrag der mehrheitsfähig ist und
deswegen bitte schließen sie sich auch
an denn wir wollen drei dinge erstens
ein im register damit wir überhaupt
wissen wer geimpft ist und dadurch eine
impfkampagne auf den weg bringen können
zweitens einen 14-tägigen bericht der
bundesregierung insbesondere
gesundheitsministers damit er das nicht
immer der handel will erklären muss
sondern auch mal dem parlament erklären
kann und drittens meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ein vorsorge
mechanismus wenn eines dieser papiere zu
dem entschluss kommt dass eine tödliche
variante da ist so tödlich wie delta und
so anstrengend wie omikron dann würden
wir mit einem mechanismus auch eine
impfpflicht nach alterskohorten
entsprechend scharf schalten all das ist
ein einigen noch vorschlag der liegt auf
den tisch und da bitten wir um
zustimmung
sepp müller stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unionsfraktion hat ein
paar minuten gebraucht um zum thema zu
kommen das sei aber nicht und ein wenig
erläutert wie der antrag der
unionsfraktionen in diesem debatte zu
diesem thema aus sieht jetzt alles beide
live die fraktion
die vorliegenden anträge für eine
impfpflicht in verschiedenen spielarten
sind das produkt von verbohrter
besessenheit und ignoranter tatsachen
verweigerung
deutschland steht diese absurden und
anachronistischen debatte wieder einmal
als europäischer sonderling da selbst
unsere nachbarn in österreich haben das
vorhaben impfpflicht vorerst ausgesetzt
die impfpflicht ist auf falschen
tatsachenbehauptungen aufgebaut dass
eine impfung
andere wirksam vor ansteckung schützt
und die ausbreitung des virus dämpft
sind fake news sie sind falsch
das muss sogar das robert-koch-institut
zu geben der versprochene schutz vor
schweren verläufen es ebenfalls
fragwürdig angesichts des wachsenden
anteils von geimpften und gebucht hatten
auf den intensivstationen
eine das gesundheitssystem gefährdende
überlastung der krankenhäuser gab es nie
es gibt sie nicht sie droht auch nicht
das hat im übrigen der
gesundheitsminister und freiwillig
zugeben müssen eine impfpflicht ist doch
nicht erforderlich um lockdown im herbst
zu verhindern lok downs verhindert man
in dem die regierung keine verhängte so
einfach ist dass die nutzlosigkeit und
schädlichkeit von logins sollte sich
inzwischen herumgesprochen haben dagegen
sind aber die potenziell nebenwirkung
der mma und vector impfstoffe weitaus
schwerer und weiter verbreitet als
ursprünglich behauptet wann wir darüber
eigentlich mal in diesem hause
gesprochen
die argumente für eine impfpflicht waren
von anfang an schwachen sie sind auch
inzwischen wie ein kartenhaus in sich
zusammen gefallen es gibt keine legitime
und verfassungsrechtlich zulässige
rechtfertigung für die einführung einer
impfpflicht gegen koubek 19 als endlich
ab 18 50 impfpflicht aus als vorrat oder
einrichtungs bezogen eine allgemeine
impfpflicht verletzt zentrale
grundrechte die menschenwürde das recht
auf leben und körperliche unversehrtheit
und das recht auf die glaubens und
gewissensfreiheit
die verhältnismäßigkeit einen derart
schweren grundrechtseingriff
legitimieren würde ist nicht gegeben die
impfpflicht ist nicht geeignet um die
angestrebten ziele zu erreichen sie ist
auch nicht erforderlich da als andere
und viel mildere therapien und maßnahmen
gibt und sie ist auch nicht angemessen
dem staat ist nicht erlaubt leben und
gesundheit einiger bürger zu gefährden
um andere bürger zu schützen die
begründung eine impfpflicht sei
notwendig um eine überlastung der
krankenhäuser zu verhindern ist nicht
nur falsch sie ist gefährlich nach
dieser pseudo logik könnte man menschen
künftig allen möglichen
behandlungen aufnötigen von der pflicht
medikation von bluthochdruck gefährdeten
bis hin zu zwangsdiät für übergewichtige
und zur begründung reicht ein politisch
selbst hergestellter kapazitätsengpass
ich hoffe sie merken selbst wie absurd
das ist die impfpflicht bis ein akt der
entrechtung sie erniedrigt millionen
menschen von souveränen mit freiheits
und abwehr rechten ausgestatteten
individuen zu befehlsempfänger und
objekten staatlicher willkür
sie treibt millionen menschen sie treibt
millionen menschen in gewissenskonflikte
und existenzielle nöte sehr geehrte
kollegen von regierungsfraktionen union
die sie einen der vorliegenden
impfpflicht anträge unterstützen sie
reiten ein totes pferd bitte steigen sie
ab ziehen sie diese anträge zurück und
lassen sie uns gemeinsam den irrweg der
einrichtungs bezogenen pflege im pflicht
so schnell wie möglich beenden so
schnell wie möglich napoli haben sie uns
schluss mit uns in diesen schweren
zeiten nicht leisten auf starrsinn und
rechthaberei die gesellschaft mit einer
impfpflicht noch weiter zu spalten für
die es weder medizinisch noch rechtlich
eine begründung gibt ich bedanke mich
der bundestag diskutiert gehör
verschiedene initiativen zum thema ins
nicht die reichen von komplette
ablehnung bis zu einer impfpflicht
18 dann gibt es auch noch die varianten
die in die zukunft gerichtet sind gegen
eine impfpflicht in jeglicher form ist
manuel höferlin und der spd fdp fraktion
und innenpolitischer sprecher wird wer
eine impfpflicht einführen will der muss
erklären wozu diese genau führen soll
und die fragen die sich mir stellen sind
schaffen wir mit der impfung eine
herdenimmunität die antwort ist nein
schöpfen schützt die impfung sicher vor
ansteckung nein schützt die impfung vor
ansteckung anderer nein
verhindern wir mit der impfpflicht eine
infektionswelle im kommenden herbst die
antwort ist nein keine frage meine damen
und herren die impfung schützt mich
wahrscheinlich vor einem schweren
verlauf und ziemlich sicher vor dem tod
deswegen habe ich mich auch impfen
lassen wo es dann lassen meine familie
hat das gemacht und ich empfehle es mit
nachdruck jedem zu machen und dafür zu
werben
daraus resultiert aber nicht die pflicht
zu einer impfung diese pflicht
einzuführen ohne eine antwort auf die
frage zu finden
ob es nicht die mildere omikron variante
dazu führt andere bewertungsmaßstäbe es
anzulegen die halte ich für
problematisch
meine damen und herren mittlerweile
haben sich die infektionszahlen auch von
den krankenhaus behandlungen von der
belegung der intensivstationen
abgekoppelt und die prognosen mancher
dass die intensivstation nun voll laufen
oder noch anders dass sie es nicht tun
wenn wir jetzt eine impfpflicht
einführen das entbehrt jeder grundlage
keine
europäischen demokratie hat aktuell die
pflicht zur impfung selbst österreich
hat sie gerade wieder außer vollzug
gesetzt mit der nachvollziehbaren
begründung unter der omicron variante
ergeben sie keinen sinn mehr
man lernt ja ja wir müssen die vulva und
gruppen schützen aber nicht vor sich
selbst denn zu behaupten für deren
schutz bräuchte es eine impfpflicht das
trägt nicht diejenigen die bis jetzt
nicht geimpft sind die wollen sich
wahrscheinlich nicht impfen lassen und
vielleicht tragen sie auch lieber eine
maske um sich zu schützen das ist ihre
entscheidung und übrigens ist das auch
ihr gutes recht das zu tun nach zwei
jahren pandemie sollten wir den menschen
aber wieder eigene entscheidungen zu
trauern für staatliche bevormundung ist
weder zeit noch
rechtlicher raum und unsere verfassung
weiter und herren sieht das schlicht
nicht vor
statt zwang wäre einsicht das gebot der
stunde doch die angekündigten
impfkampagnen die mit viel geld
finanziert und entweder verpufft sind
oder noch auf ihre umsetzung warten
dazu machen wie ein amt in unserem
antrag konkrete vorschläge und lassen
sie mich noch einmal klarstellen die
entscheidung über die eigene gesundheit
und das eigene leben liegt am ende immer
noch bei jedem selbst
in der verantwortung von uns im
deutschen bundestag liegt es aber
hingegen bei anderen erkenntnisse auch
andere wege zu gehen was im letzten
herbst noch gegolten hat ist nach der
heutigen erkenntnislage vielleicht
anders und deshalb lassen sie uns heute
und im weiteren verlauf offen und
ehrlich diskutieren nicht nur darüber
was als nötig empfunden wird sondern was
wirklich bürgerinnen bürgern hilft und
was rechtlich möglich ist herzlichen
dank
wie manuel höferlin
in diesem fall nicht für die komplette
fdp fraktion aber die in der fdp und den
anderen fraktionen die er gegen und dann
eine pflicht gesehen und wir bleiben
quasi bei der fdp aber bei einer geld
kommen zu einer ganz anderen position
nämlich zu der von android an grooven
und anderen abgeordneten im parlament
die sich für eine beratungs lösung und
eine impfpflicht bei bedarf aus
das system vor überlastung schützen
und diese belastungen können wir nur
schützen indem wir die krankheitslast
reduzieren und alle krankheitsbild dann
reduziert werde eine gewisse
grundimmunisierung in unserer
bevölkerung haben und das ist das
fundament ist wir brauchen unser weg ist
aber ein anderer ein ziel ist relativ
klar ausgesprochen unser wenn ich das
gesetzesentwurf ist sagt klar wir
vertrauen den menschen eine richtige
entscheidung zu treffen nur um diese
richtige entscheidung zu treffen bedarf
es einer professionellen guten
aufklärung und deshalb setzen wir uns ja
auch dafür ein eine verpflichtende
aufklärung für diejenigen in den weg zu
bringen auf den weg zu bringen damit sie
eine gute entscheidung machen können
damit sie weniger ängste und
unsicherheiten haben diese
verpflichtende beratung meine damen und
herren ist ein milderes mittel im
vergleich zu einer impfpflicht denn eine
impfpflicht darf nur eine ultima ratio
sein und nicht eine sofortige umsetzung
dieser situation
wir wollen die impflücken schließen vor
allem die impflücken der wohlhabenden
personen und das bis zum herbst der
einst ziel sollte uns eigentlich einigen
wir müssen die wohlhabenden menschen
schützen vor krankenhausaufenthalte die
wir letztes jahr vorletztes jahr erlebt
mit cupid 19 und dieses gesetz würde ein
gesamtkonzept der pandemie bekämpfung
auch gut hineinpassen unser
gesetzentwurf baute brückenbau brücke
mit den anderen anträgen die wir hier im
bundestag haben wir wollen uns ja lade
ich alle
demokraten in diesem parlament auf mit
zu arbeiten dass wir eine lösung für
unser land bekommen dass wir weihnachten
dieses jahr mit unseren leben mit
unseren freund so feiern können wie wir
es gewohnt sind denn das haben wir heute
in der hand wir heute etwas nicht ändern
da sind wir verloren und haben wieder
ein weihnachten gewiss letzten zwei
jahre erlebt haben und das wollen wir
eigentlich verhindern und deshalb frage
ich bitte ich um die zusammenarbeit und
spätere zustimmung zu diesem gesetz
herzliches danke danke schön herr
ullmann war das entschuldigung der für
seinen antrag den er gemeinsam mit einer
ganzen reihe anderer abgeordneten auch
aus anderen fraktionen geworben hat also
möglichst viele intensive beratung und
erst wenn die impfquote zu niedrig ist
auch eine impfpflicht ab 50 jahren der
bundeswirtschaftsminister steht schon
wenn er ist der nächste redner in dieser
debatte robert habeck und er spricht
auch für den antrag den gesetzentwurf
für eine generelle impfpflicht
impfpflicht ab 18 also für die
allgemeine impfpflicht mit 18 und ich
will das auch gleich begründen zuvor
würde ich gerne eine anmerkung machen
dass wir hier diskutieren und dass wir
uns für den weg entschieden haben
gruppenanträge zu gehen den weg der
gruppenanträge zugehen entbindet uns
natürlich nicht von der pflicht eine
lösung zu finden am ende wäre das
schlimmste wenn es keine lösung geben
würde ja es ist eine moralisch komplexe
abwägung die wir jetzt alle vornehmen
müssen aber ich will ausdrücklich sagen
die individuelle gewissensentscheidung
kann nicht dazu führen dass wir der
verantwortung zum wohle der menschen in
diesem lande am ende nicht gerecht
werden
die sich eben kurz darüber ausgetauscht
ob man hinter eine debatte zu kleine
oder nicht führen können hätte man diese
debatte geführt hätte man überhaupt
stimmen über krisen geführt gäbe es
einen übergang zu dieser debatte nämlich
die frage und das ist die frage die
beantwortet werden muss tun wir alles um
vorsorge zu treffen die vorsorge frage
ist die frage wie wir mit den krisen
umgehen und vorsorge bedeutet denken in
eventualitäten maske alles noch
passieren diese frage nicht der status
quo nicht die amicom variante steht im
mittelpunkt der debatte sondern tun wir
alles dafür dieses land und ihre
menschen zu schützen vor wieder großen
freiheitseinschränkung und wenn man das
wenn man das sich klar macht worum es
eigentlich geht dann muss man
feststellen erstens das virus ist
typischer lisa und mutanten reicher als
wir es uns vor zwei oder drei jahren
überhaupt haben träumen lassen 21
menschen sind aus guten oder schlechten
gründen widerwilliger sich zu schützen
von diesem virus und damit kriegen wir
nicht den grundschutz in der
gesellschaft
viertens die freiheits abwägung bzw die
als interpretation der wenigen darf
nicht zur permanenten
freiheitseinschränkung der vielen führen
das kann nicht der deal sein
wir stimmen also bei der frage darüber
ab ob wir am ende wieder an ein regime
einkehren wollen dass das kulturelle
liegen leben zum alarm bringt das kinder
und menschen die es nicht zu dicke haben
in die situation zwingt das wieder
massive freiheits einbußen und unter
untersagung des öffentlichen lebens bzw
gesellschaftlichen lebens einkehrt das
müssen wir doch mal durchbrechen das
müssen wir doch verhindern darum geht es
doch im kern
ich würde dir einer liga stelle sagen
wir haben es satt die menschen in diesem
land haben es hat bringen wir diese
pandemie endlich hinter uns erledigen
wir das virus und kehren gedanken zur
freiheit zurück ja es wäre besser
gewesen menschen hätten sich freiwillig
in großer zahl impfen lassen das wäre
natürlich die bessere lösung gewesen
aber dass sie es nicht getan haben und
bindet dieses haus und uns alle nicht
von der verantwortung dafür zu sorgen
dass wir wieder ein freies leben in
deutschland führen können vom nicht mit
einstellung von leben deswegen deswegen
für einen antrag der die herren die
immunität in deutschland hoch hält für
dass wir wieder das virus besiegen
können dankeschön
robert habeck der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
und der nächste redner ist tino sorge
aus der unionsfraktion wo er auch
gesundheitspolitischer sprecher ist und
deswegen mutmassen mal dass er für den
unionsantrag antrag eintreten wird
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrter herr habe ich sie
haben vollkommen recht wir hätten schon
viel viel früher hier über dieses thema
in diesem plenum debattieren müssen und
dass wir das eben nicht getan haben dass
wir nicht früher darüber debattiert
haben das lag an bundeskanzler scholz
das lag an bundesgesundheitsminister
lauterbach die noch ende letzten jahres
vollmundig bekundet haben sie seien für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht haben aber
nicht die kraft besessen hier in diesem
hohen haus einen kompromissfähigen
antrag einzubringen genau das ist das
problem
und deshalb haben wir jetzt die
situation wie wir sie haben sie haben
den weg der gruppenanträge gewählt mit
unsicheren mehrheiten sehr langsam und
wissen letztendlich nicht wie die ganze
sache ausgeht und wenn jetzt immer
argumentiert wird wir müssten doch jetzt
alle an einem strang ziehen dann
erklären sie doch mal wie dieser strang
aussieht und wir haben als einzige
fraktion hier gesagt die unterbreiten
einen kompromissvorschlag wir sind fast
200 kolleginnen und kollegen in der
unionsfraktion und wir haben genau das
getan was die aufgabe der ampel gewesen
wäre nämlich ein kompromissvorschlag für
dieses komplexe thema zu unterbreiten
und deshalb höre ich immer in den
letzten tagen es wäre ja schön wenn man
sich hier im hohen hause einigen würde
wenn man einen kompromiss finden würde
ich sage ihnen ganz klar dieser
kompromiss liegt seit wochen auf dem
tisch ist der im vorsorge mechanismus
unserer fraktion liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und deshalb kann ich ihnen auch nur noch
mal sagen es geht hier bei diesem thema
nicht um pauschale lösung wir haben ein
sehr komplexes problem wir haben
geänderte rahmenbedingungen wie haben
wir der omicron variante höhere
infektionszahlen aber viel viel milde
verläufe und deshalb wäre es völlig
falsch mit einer pauschalen lösung wie
hier suggeriert wird also alle sollen
sich impfen lassen im festjahr aber alle
menschen zu zwingen sich impfen lassen
wird nicht dazu führen dass wir das
problem lösen das liegt erstens daran
bei dir nicht differenzieren bei dem
antrag im pflicht für alle deshalb haben
wir gesagt als unionsfraktion wir
brauchen einen im vorsorgen mechanismus
das heißt wir schauen uns an haben wir
überhaupt eine ordentliche
datengrundlage genau das doch das
kernproblem die reden seit über zwei
jahren darüber dass wir die menschen zum
impfen animieren wollen wir wissen gar
nicht wer geimpft ist und deshalb ist
die klare forderung diesem antrag ein in
frigges soll damit sie erstmal die
datengrundlage haben um genau diese
bekämpfen zu können zweiter punkt es
bringt doch nichts jetzt zu sagen alle
sollen sich impfen lassen natürlich
helfen uns impfungen jeder kann
individuell entscheiden im funktionen
dazu dass ich keine schweren verläufe
habe aber die impfung mit den jetzigen
impfstoffen gibt uns doch nicht die
gewähr dafür dass wir im herbst für eine
variante die wir momentan überhaupt noch
nicht kennen mit einem impfstoff den die
momentan überhaupt noch nicht haben dass
wir damit aus dieser dauerschleife
herauskommt und deshalb liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen geht es um
differenzierung und genau das tut unser
antrag denn unser antrag
nimmt auch die notwendige
differenzierung vor liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wir sagen erstens wir
brauchen die infrastruktur die wird
vorgehalten wenn sich die lage
verschlechtert heißt dass wir können es
schnell wieder hochfahren gleichzeitig
sagen die aber auch wir müssen
wissenschaftlich evaluiert
wissenschaftlich determiniert sagen
können welche gruppen betrifft es wer
hat ein hohes risiko können wir diese
gruppen damit schützen haben die ein
geeignetes mittel oder als letzten punkt
dieses mittel muss verhältnismäßig sein
und die verhältnismäßigkeit ist nur dann
gegeben wenn wir damit auch das sie was
wir erreichen wollen nämlich schutz der
politik erreichen können und deshalb ich
komme zum schluss braucht präsidentin
stimmen sie unserem vorsorge mechanismus
zur das ist der einzige sinnvolle
kompromisse und gangbare weg hätten sie
drei wie der ministerin ab mit
parteipolitik weil der hass
parteipolitik ist dass wir als
opposition vorschläge unterbreiten oder
die regierung kritisieren dafür nicht er
ist ja so dass ich finde ich das als
kompliment
sie können das gerne als kompliment
erfinden aber nicht meine ermahnung dass
nämlich nicht an weil wir haben ja alle
noch sehr prozent ihre zeiten in dieser
debatte und deswegen kann ich nicht
jetzt locker sagen sie durften 50
minuten 40 sekunden minuten überziehen
dank für die konstruktive hinter heißt
ich denke am ende aber wenn du mit meine
rede danke für die aufmerksamkeit an
ausgebrannten zurück jetzt hat
ja das ist vielleicht auch noch mal ein
richtiger hinweis auch für sie die diese
debatte verfolgen die längste redezeit
die hier eingeräumt wird in der debatte
geht beispielsweise für den bremer
bürgermeister andreas bovenschulte der
nachher noch kommt die allermeisten
haben drei manchmal auch nur zwei
minuten martin sicherheit aus der
fdp-fraktion hat drei
kontakt mit einem positiv getesteten
kind hatte forderte mich das
gesundheitsamt auf ich solle zitat
möglichst innerhalb des haushalts
getrennte räume nutzen und gemeinsame
mahlzeiten vermeiden bei einer
zweijährigen dass meine damen und herren
ist staatliche aufforderung zur
kindesmisshandlung
so weit so weit konnte es nur kommen
weil man die maßnahmen von der realität
von daten fakten und echtem
gesundheitsschutz völlig entkoppelt hat
laut daten der betriebskrankenkassen gab
es bis august mehr
arbeitsunfähigkeitstage wegen
impfnebenwirkungen als nach einem
positiven corona test mehr
arbeitsunfähigkeit wegen
impfnebenwirkungen als nach positiven
kroner test diese impfung meine damen
und herren ist eindeutig nicht sicher
der kölner karneval bei 2g plus war ein
super sprecher event das beweist dass
die impfung keinen ausreichenden schutz
bietet auch der eigenschutz funktioniert
nicht es sind mehr corona
intensivpatienten gepustet als ungeimpft
eine impfpflicht ohne ausreichende
sicherheit oder wirksamkeit des
impfstoffes ist nur eines eindeutig
verfassungswidrig
auch gesundheitspolitisch gibt es keine
grundlage für eine impfpflicht in den
letzten beiden jahren waren jeweils
zweieinhalb millionen patienten weniger
in den krankenhäusern als 2009 10 auch
auf den intensivstationen liegen seit
monaten deutlich weniger menschen als im
durchschnitt 18 1091 waren es letzten
sonntag das ist der niedrigste jemals
gemessene wert an intensiv patienten
eine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
drohte nie zu jedem zeitpunkt in den
letzten zwei jahren waren tausende
intensivbetten verfügbar
was aber fehlt sind wichtige studien zur
impfung man gibt erbgut des virus in den
menschlichen körper und weiß bis heute
nicht was danach passiert wie verhält
sich der impfstoff genau im körper wie
verteilt er sich in welchen organen
welche auswirkungen hat die m rna noch
neben das bike proteinproduktion welche
schäden können durch das bike protein
passieren fragen über fragen die niemand
beantworten kann weil das nicht
ausreichend erforscht ist
meine damen und herren
realsatire ist wenn alle bundestags
präsidentin geimpft sind vier von sechs
ancona erkrankt sind und der bundestag
trotz dieser offensichtlichen
unwirksamkeit über eine impfpflicht
diskutiert
die anderen länder haben begriffen dass
maßnahmen mehr schaden als nutzen nein
zu impfpflicht nein zur bewohner willkür
beenden wir es endlich auch in
deutschland vielen dank und
zu ende ist auch die redezeit von martin
gesichert aus der spd-fraktion tabea
rößner wird die nächste rednerin seien
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
und sie ist gegen das licht
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
uns eint das ziel die pandemie zu
bewältigen und die überlastung des
gesundheitswesens abzuwenden ein guter
immunstatus trägt wesentlich dazu bei
uneins sind wir uns ob eine impfpflicht
das geeignete instrumente ist diese
differenz zieht sich durch die
gesellschaft durch familien wissenschaft
und parteien selten wurde so emotional
diskutiert die menschen gerade die
jungen sehnen sich nach normalität und
das ist nur verständlich
und haben viele menschen auch zahlreiche
geimpfte geschrieben dass sie eine
impfentscheidung selbst treffen wollen
viele haben ängste einige berichten von
starken impfreaktionen dem
paul-ehrlich-institut liegen nur
gemeldeten nebenwirkungen im schäden vor
wie hoch die dunkelziffer ist wissen wir
nicht wir sollten die fälle systematisch
erfassen damit nehmen wir die bedenken
ernst und das schafft auch vertrauen
nikon hat die lage grundlegend verändert
wir wissen nicht welchen shops die
impfung beim neuen varianten bietet und
eine sterile immunität so führen die
biologen kann mit einer impfpflicht
nicht erreicht werden wenn ich mir aber
die die höhere fürchte ich dass genau
diese erwartungen geweckt wird und das
führt auch zu weiteren frust nach
heutigem stand geht es bei der impfung
er um den eigen als um den fremdschutz
und daher ist eine impfpflicht noch
schwieriger zu rechtfertigen und die
aufgabe die aufgabe des staates ist
nicht die menschen vor sich selbst zu
schützen sondern das gesundheitssystem
am laufen zu halten
wir brauchen niedrigschwellige
beratungsangebote mehr forschung eine
bessere datenlage und eine wirksame
anhaltender immunstatus nach einer
durchgemachten infektion sollte
angesichts des erheblichen
grundrechtseingriff
anerkannt werden kollegen bei der brücke
tausend fragen
beantworten bei der beurteilung der uni
immunität der bevölkerung sollte auch
die zahl der durch eine infektion
immunisierten menschen berücksichtigt
werden ist die reduzierung habe weniger
alarmismus und mehr sachlichkeit neue
erkenntnisse juden in der wissenschaft
dazu positionen zu revidieren daran
sollten wir uns mehr politik am beispiel
neben
größen aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen mit einem dreier gegen eine
allgemeine eben sich leicht dagegen
beendet die mit immer das licht immer
sozusagen sondern ein drittel länger ist
wenn man eine halbe minute über zieht
das geht natürlich
ich mir total nicht so streng aber
streng
dr paula potter hat jetzt das wort für
die gruppe janitschek ullmann und andere
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin und
erstmal herzlichen dank dass sie mit
petra pau hier diese woche diesen
wahnsinns job machen allein zu zweit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die pflicht ist offensichtlich nicht
mehr das wichtigste thema in diesem haus
das sieht man auch hier greifen aber ich
glaube sie kann unglaublich wichtiger
baustein sein und hinweisgeber bei der
frage ob wir die vielen verschiedenen
krisen die wir jetzt gerade alle
gemeinsam lösen müssen ob wir dieser
verantwortung als dieses haus wirklich
gerecht werden und ich verstehe sehr gut
dass viele bei dieser frage keinen
kompromiss machen wollen aber gerade vor
dem hintergrund der vielen krisen die
wir jetzt alle auf einmal bewältigen
müssen dürfen kompromisse nicht
schlechtgeredet werden und ich verstehe
jeden die gruppe über 18 ich verstehe
jeden der das gefühl hat hier könnte
sich eventuell am ende nicht die beste
variante durchsetzen aber ich möchte
darum bitten dann trotzdem nicht alles
beiseite zu wischen was man auch mit
einer teillösung noch erreichen kann
gerade für die pflege jeder der sich
aufgeregt hat darüber dass für die
pflege nur vom balkon geklatscht wurde
der kann jetzt hier über seinen eigenen
schatten springen und zumindest
erreichen dass die überlastung des
gesundheitswesens und damit die
belastung der vielen menschen die in
diesen gesundheitswesen arbeiten und
gerade jeden monat kolleginnen und
kollegen verlieren dass zumindest der
vorgebeugt wird
und ich glaube am ende wird sich auch
hier entscheiden ob wir dieser
verantwortung gerecht werden die jetzt
auf unseren schultern liegt und ich habe
heute nicht in jeder minute in diesem
haus das gefühl gehabt dass dieser
bundestag sich seiner verantwortung
bewusst ist aber wenn wir gut sind wenn
wir richtig gut sind dann werden wir
auch am ende dieses prozesses zeigen
dass auch wenn es schwierig ist das auch
wenn es kompliziert ist auch wenn viele
menschen gerade auch jüngere menschen
bei uns sehr mit sich ringen und die
aktuell auf dem tisch liegenden
kompromisslösung nicht gut finden dass
wir es trotzdem schaffen am ende ich
hier eine mehrheit dafür zu haben die
lebensbedingungen in diesem land und die
möglichkeit für alle patientinnen gerade
auch die vielen menschen die jetzt
gerade neu zu uns kommt im herbst in
einem gut funktionierenden
gesundheitssystems zu erhalten vielen
dank
[Applaus]
sehen wir uns kathrin henning da spricht
jetzt für die gruppe während und anderen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren was ist unsere aufgabe
als politik ich bin aus tiefstem herzen
liberale also lautet meine antwort zu
tun was notwendig ist und zu unterlassen
was nicht unbedingt notwendig ist
andersherum
politik muss sich wann immer möglich
heraushalten und menschen ihr leben
selbstbestimmt führen lassen gerade
deswegen streite ich für die allgemeinen
pflicht
es ist rechtlich bereits einschränkungen
jetzt zurück zu fahren und gleichzeitig
die erwartungshaltung zu kommunizieren
dass jeder sofern noch nicht geschehen
bis zum herbst einen vollständigen
impfschutz erwirbt ich möchte nicht nur
dass wir so schnell wie möglich
beschränkungen zurücknehmen können ich
möchte dass wir sie nicht jeden herbst
neu einführen müssen dass wir in zukunft
überhaupt nicht mehr in diese maßnahme
spirale geraten
freiheit ist nicht nur freiheit
verspritzen freiheit ist auch in schule
und kita zu lernen und zu spielen ist
auch die freiheit gesetzt
ein schicker und
theaterschauspieler und messebauer ihrem
beruf nachgehen zu können
freiheit bedeutet sich bei integration
einer krankenhausbehandlung unterziehen
zu können und nicht auf das abflachende
aktuellen corona welle warten zu müssen
freilich ist auch im altern mit der
familie ins leere reihen geburtstag
feiern zu dürfen meine damen und herren
auf dem rücken all dieser menschen wird
die viel zu geringe
impfstraßen menschen gegenüber besteht
auch eine schutzpflicht des staates
grundstück abwehrrechte gegenüber dem
staat sie sollen den staat zwingen sich
zu rechtfertigen wenn er in die von
ihnen geschützten rechtsgüter eingreift
sie sollen ihn nicht zur untätigkeit
verdammt um bei einer aktuellen corona
welle kurzfristig eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems entgegenzuwirken
haben wir inzwischen ein instrumentarium
entwickelt
aber die anwendung dieser instrumente in
der lässt massive kollateralschäden
lassen sie uns das so gut es geht vom
haydn gehen wir mit einer umfassenden
pflichtigen impfkampagne einen anderen
weg denken wir weiter denn auch das
virus mutiert weiter wir haben ein
konzept vorgelegt das noch einmal auf
umfassende informationen setzt am ende
aber auch eine klare erwartung
kommuniziert wir schlagen eine umsetzung
vor die für die allermeisten ganz
unkompliziert erfüllbar ist mit einem
einfachen upload oder einem gang in die
apotheke machen wir das und ja es gibt
das risiko dass wir die impfpflicht am
ende nicht gebraucht haben werden
dagegen abzuwägen ist das risiko dass
wir uns alle und unsere kinder erneut
stark zurücknehmen müssen für mich ist
das ergebnis der abwägung klar vielen
dank
deshalb hat den hallen klar aus der fdp
fraktion die sich ausgesprochen hat für
den entwurf für den gesetzentwurf der
hier untergruppe behrens läuft also für
eine impfpflicht ab 18 also wir sehen in
der spd bei den grünen auch bei der fdp
es gibt es unterschiedliche auffassungen
gibt es möglicherweise auch in der
unionsfraktion aber da ist man noch
recht geschlossen was die auftritte in
dieser debatte hier angeht und ich
vermute das wird jetzt auch so sein wenn
andrea lindholz der stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
hier fällt es immer noch schwer an
dieser stelle zur impfpflicht zu
sprechen ich stehe immer noch unter den
eindrücken der rede des ukrainischen
präsidenten und ich will an dieser
stelle nur eines sagen bevor ich zum
eigentlichen thema gekommen es wäre
anständig gewesen es wäre da wäre
angemessen gewesen es wäre erforderlich
gewesen dass die fraktionen in diesem
bundestag die möglichkeit gehabt hätten
unmittelbar auf diese rede zu antworten
und ihre solidarität zu bekunden und das
war keine glanzstunde was dieses
parlament hier heute morgen abgeleistet
hat
wir beraten in dieser woche zu dem
wichtigen thema der pandemie zwei
vorhaben
die liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der ampel wollen morgen in der zweiten
lesung die masken pflicht im rahmen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
quasi abschaffen die verpflichtende
masken pflicht im öffentlichen raum zu
einer zeit in der die inzidenz
2651 liegt zu einer zeit in der die
korona fälle täglich bei knapp 300.000
liegen und die todesfälle über 200
betragen sie wollen die masken pflicht
abschaffen und sie tun das morgen mit
ihrer mehrheit wir werden ausdrücklich
nicht zustimmen die maske schützt direkt
und unmittelbar denjenigen der sie trägt
und das gegenüber die masken pflicht ist
kein großer eingriff in die grundrechte
die massen pflicht ist das mildeste und
geeignete mittel um der jetzigen
situation schutz vor dem corona virus zu
bieten gerade auch weil der rahmen
person ich will ihnen sagen wenn sie
eine personen mit einer immunschwäche
sind weil sie eine schwere erkrankung
haben und sie müssen einkaufen gehen sie
müssen nicht ins restaurant gehen aber
sie müssen einkaufen gehen und sie
versuchen täglich zu verhindern dass sie
sich anstecken dann sind sie demnächst
schutzlos sie können selber freiwillig
noch eine maske tragen aber ob das
gegenüber eine maske trägt bleibt ihrem
gegenüber freiwillig überlassen und ich
finde dass zum jetzigen zeitpunkt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
verantwortungslos natürlich muss man
auch über die reduzierung der masken
pflicht sprechen aber doch bitte zu
einem zeitpunkt der angemessen und
richtig ist ich kann das beim besten
willen nicht nachvollziehen was sie sich
hier überlebt haben und die gleichen
kolleginnen und kollegen die morgen der
abschaffung der masken pflicht der
verpflichtenden massen pflicht zustimmen
werden sprechen sie hier in großen
teilen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt für eine
sofortige impfpflicht aus es tut mir
wirklich leid es ist wirklich chaos was
bei ihm in der gesundheitspolitik
herrscht
wir wissen bei der info dass sie für den
herbst als vorbereitung wichtig ist das
heißt unser antrag die ganz klar vor die
impfkampagne weiterzufahren wir wollen
auch vorbereitet sein für den herbst
deswegen sagen mit unserem in vorsorge
antrag auch ganz klar bitte führen sie
endlich des zwingend notwendige register
ein wir brauchen den überblick über den
status wir müssen personen gezielt
ansprechen können auch was booster
impfungen angeht wir müssen die
ungeimpften noch einmal gezielt
ansprechen können und wir müssen mit
einer validen daten lage endlich die
pandemie vernünftig steuern können in
dieser lage jetzt und zum dritten
haben wir mit unserem antrag ein
mechanismus vorgesehen der dann wenn es
nötig und erforderlich ist einen
stufenweisen impf mechanismus in gang
setzt und dafür müssen sie jetzt
sozusagen in einem monitoring die die
infektionszahlen der über 60-jährigen
beachten den erlernten die situation auf
den intensivstationen kollegen wenn wir
das tun dann können wir auch
zielgerichtet agieren und deswegen bitte
ich sie auch unsere figuren vernünftigen
attraktion zu stehen und da auch ein
gutes gesetz zu machen resümiert
richtige vorsorge für den kollegen kommt
und ich bitte sie auch morgen nicht der
entwurf belegen sie und die sind zu
zweit über die redezeit hinausgegangen
und
realisierter noch mal schnell hermann
von der bundestags vizepräsidentin der
bundestag diskutiert über die
impfpflicht unter lohnt ein blick auf
die impfquote im moment bundesweit
mindestens einer gegend derzeit 76 5
prozent der bevölkerung die
grundimmunisierung also mit zwei
empfehlen 75,8 prozent und personen mit
auffrischimpfung 58 prozent das ist
angesichts von omikron meint weiteren
varianten zu wenig sagen leute die sich
mit dem thema auskennt
jetzt gibt noch eine ermahnung für die
die hier ihre maske am nicht korrekt
tragen und das haben sie im laufe der
debatte schon gesehen in welcher
fraktionen dass vor allem so gehandhabt
wird zwischenrufen oder gesprächen mit
der nachbarin oder dem nachbarn ich
bitte sie das zu berücksichtigen ich
habe gestern hier schon damit drohen
müssen dass es ordnungsmaßnahmen gibt
und jetzt gebe ich das wort dem kollegen
dr andreas bovenschulte dem
bürgermeister von bremen für die gruppe
während
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren abgeordnete im land
bremen sind ca 90 prozent der menschen
einmal geimpft die zahl der doppelt
geimpft licht etwas darunter und fast
zwei drittel sind auch schon gebucht
hatten und ich muss sagen
ich muss sagen wir sind auch ein
bisschen stolz auf diese zahlen denn sie
sind das ergebnis einer großen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen
kraftanstrengung von politik und
verwaltung von hilfsorganisationen und
heimischer wirtschaft wir haben
leistungsfähige impfzentren aufgebaut
wir sind mit unseren impf trucks in die
quartiere gefahren die haben dezentrale
angebote in unseren bürgerhäusern
gemacht wir haben mehrsprachige
gesundheits fachkräfte in die quartiere
geschickt wo die impfquoten besonders
niedrig sind wir haben geworden wir
haben diskutiert werden auch gestritten
und wir haben es dadurch durch die
ansprache der gesamten bevölkerung
geschafft ein richtig gutes im klima im
land zu schaffen mit argumenten ohne
druck und ohne zwang
und trotzdem meine damen und herren
spreche ich mich heute für die
einführung einer allgemeinen pflicht in
deutschland aus eine position übrigens
die ich hier nicht alleine verträge
sondern stellvertretend für die 16
ministerpräsidenten
und ministerpräsidentin die sich schon
mehrfach
auf ihren konferenzen ganz klar und
eindeutig hinter dieser forderung
versammelt
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
wenn jetzt die impfquote bundesweit
stagniert obwohl ausreichend impfstoff
jederzeit verfügbar sind und wohl es
ausreichend informationen zum impfen in
allen möglichen sprachen gibt dann
stellt sich schon die frage welche
schlüsse müssen wir daraus ziehen eine
erkenntnis aus meiner sicht zentral die
meisten die sich bisher nicht haben
impfen lassen werden diesen schritt ohne
eine gesetzliche pflicht auch künftig
nicht geben das könnten wir jetzt
natürlich einfach hinnehmen als ausdruck
individueller freiheit betätigung
wirklich klug meine damen und herren
wäre das aber nicht denn die meisten
dieser menschen werden sich über kurz
oder lang infizieren etliche werden
mangels impfung schwer erkranken müssen
in krankenhäusern und auf den
intensivstationen behandelt werden und
spätestens dann wenn die kliniken an
ihre belastungsgrenzen stoßen sollten
wäre das für uns alle ein problem dann
wäre das nicht mehr ausdruck
individueller
freiheitsbewegung sondern ein tiefes
grundlegendes gesellschaftliches problem
dann müssten wir hier in den roten wir
beschränkungen teil ob das beim drohten
wieder schließung von geschäften schulen
und kitas dann drohten wieder kontakt
beschränkungen
ökonomischen nicht zuletzt die sozialen
folgen immer wiederkehrender
beschränkung zyklen sind enorm als
bürgermeister in den vergangenen wochen
und monaten viele gespräche mit eltern
und schülerinnen und schülern mit
unternehmern mit vertretern von
sportvereinen von kirchen von verbänden
geführt und ich kann ihn einst
versichern die menschen wollen und
können nicht mehr ich kann jedem nur
dringend empfehlen sich einmal mit einer
allein erziehenden berufstätigen mutter
zu unterhalten und darüber zu sprechen
was monatelange schul und lieber
schließung mit ihr gemacht haben meine
damen und herren die familien in
deutschland sind wirklich am limit um
ist deshalb
ganz klar und deutlich zu sagen wenn wir
die pandemie ohne impfpflicht hinter uns
lassen können das wäre gut das wäre
schön wenn wir aber nun die wahl haben
zwischen einer ständigen beschränkung
und laubbaum gefahr und der impfpflicht
dann sollten wir uns für die impfpflicht
entscheiden
meine damen und herren ich habe es
einfach gesagt als der ministerpräsident
ministerpräsidenten haben wir uns mehr
einmütig hinter der allgemeinen pflicht
versammelt zuletzt vor vier wochen
insbesondere kolleginnen und kollegen
war stets ein großes anliegen eine
entsprechende forderung in die mpk
beschlüsse aufzunehmen deshalb hoffe ich
sehr dass am ende auch herr kollegen der
union einen allgemeinen gesetzlichen
pflicht zustimmen werden herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
ausgesprochen hat und jetzt gibt es auch
einen redner aus der linksfraktion die
regel und ausnahme schreitet zum schuld
und diese internationale gregor gysi
wird mal gerade eine einzige minute
redezeit
nicht mehr möglich ja vielleicht bin ich
auch so streng weil wir bis heute nacht
hier zurzeit sitzen aber nehmen sie es
dann als persönliche betroffenheit das
können sie gerne genau
das macht aber nichts jetzt habe ich
nämlich dem kollegen dr gregor gysi das
wort zu geben für die gruppe kubicki und
für eine minute
auch präsident meine christe rede in der
geschichte des bundestages ich bin
dreimal geimpft und genesen mehr geht
gar nicht aber ich bin ein strikter
gegner der allgemeinen hin pflicht beim
asam war ich dafür weil das die
krankheit aus rottete das schafft der
impfstoff hier nicht eigentlich brauchen
wir eine aufklärung 30 pro tag und
bremen hat sich ja geschafft auch dank
unserer linken sozialsenatorin
geldbußen sind für mich der falsche weg
und wenn sie regeln ist die dürfen nicht
umgewandelt werden in haftstrafen dann
werden die anderen die bei denen
umgewandelt wird welchen der geldbußen
vor das bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen
viel spaß wegen der gleichheit dann gibt
es jetzt den wunsch nach einer
zwischenfrage möchten sie das zulassen
ergeben
[Applaus]
ich weiß es nicht die dafür gezahlt
haben
herr kollege bitte die zwischenfrage ist
zugelassen ich hoffe dass jetzt keine
marktwirtschaftliche angegliederte
person umfrage dass ich den rest ihrer
unterbringen
ja viel deutlicher kollege die sie dass
diese zwischenfrage zu lassen und ich
bin überzeugt dass sie die letzten
sekunden auch noch hinbekommen werden
meine frage an sie konkret ist was ist
ihre lösung die krankheitslast für den
kommenden winter den durchaus
hypothetischer passieren könnte
eigentlich begegnen wollen weil das ist
ja keine lösung wir wollen nicht impfen
oder gewonnen kann im pflicht einführen
wie wollen sie die restliche diese im
pflücke eigentlich schließen die ist ja
dass sich momentan in einer lösung ja
ich sag dir gerade ich sagte gerade das
geld 30.000 menschen pro tag überzeugen
müssen und ich bin es kann uns gelingen
wenn wir so machen wie es in bremen
gemacht worden ist wenn man das überall
machen und
außerdem will ich noch sagen wir haben
jetzt 16 millionen nicht geimpfte mal
angenommen fünf millionen machten das
nach der pflicht ein bleiben elf
millionen übrig people hunderttausende
ordnungsämter brauchen wir denn
eigentlich um das durchzusetzen ein
gesetz dass man nicht durchsetzen kann
darf man auch nicht beschließen franke
[Applaus]
kathrin vogler spricht jetzt zu uns für
die gruppe behrens und andere
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen lieber
brieger diese ich schätze dich als
mensch und politiker bei die liegst du
einfach falsch inzwischen dürfte doch in
deutschland fast jeder jemanden kennen
die oder der gerade wegen cockpit 19
krank oder in quarantäne ist wir haben
aktuell eine inzidenz fast dreimal so
hoch wie in vergleichbaren ländern
täglich mehr als 200 tote zunehmende
krankenhauseinweisungen und auch wieder
mehr menschen und zwar vor allem
ungeimpfte auf den intensivstationen
auch von unseren kolleginnen sind einige
die heute mit diskutieren wollten wegen
corbett 19 nicht bei uns und ich wünsche
ihnen glaube in ihrer aller namen dass
sie sie dass sie schnell und vor allem
vollständig gewesen
selbstverständlich ist das nicht immer
mehr menschen leiden langfristig und das
schweren folgen selbst wenn die
infektion leicht verlaufen ist die
autorin margaret des stokowski
beschreibt ihre erfahrungen mit long
koppelt in ihrer jüngsten spiegel
kolumne kolumne eine kolumne sie
ansonsten einfach mal so leicht
unterschrieb die er jetzt aber alle
kraft und viel zeit abverlangt falls es
hier interessiert ich habe jetzt seit
zwei monaten täglich kopfschmerzen und
bin von jeder kleinigkeit erschöpft ich
habe immer wieder schwächeanfälle für
mehrere stunden nun dazu ein übriges
kribbeln null hunger oder appetit mein
gehirn funktioniert nicht richtig und
ich schlafe oft 14 stunden und bin
danach absolut nicht erholt sondern
genauso kaputt wie am tag davor
meine damen und herren vor longo wird
kann man sich nicht individuell schützen
der beste schutz davor ist eine hohe
impfrate in der bevölkerung leben fasten
abstand und all den maßnahmen der kennt
weil geimpfte einfach weniger ansteckend
sind und es gibt auch einen messbaren
zusammenhang zwischen der impfquote
unter sterblichkeit und dennoch haben
wir es nicht überall geschafft so wie in
bremen die impflücken zu schließen und
jeder der glaubt dass wir das bis zum
sommer schaffen weil er wenn dann die
infektionszahlen sinken und es keine
zweig regel mehr gibt der glaubt auch
noch in die zahnfee es gehört einfach
zur menschlichen natur gefahren die
nicht akut erscheinen zu verdrängen und
und erst dann zu handeln wenn sie
wirklich ein im persönlichen umfeld
auftauchen aber wenn im herbst dieses
jahres die nächste corona welle anrollt
der weiß mit welchem virus dann wird es
zu spät sein wenn wir dann nicht über
lockt uns kontakt beschränkungen über
oder schulschließungen reden wollen dann
müssen wir jetzt handeln und
nein die idee menschen per gesetz zum
impfen zu verpflichten die begeistert
mich überhaupt nicht und ich habe viel
kritik an einer politik die es überhaupt
erst so weit hat kommen lassen aber nach
zwei jahren mit immer wiederholten
freiheits einschränkungen und all ihren
sozialen und gesellschaftlichen
verwüstungen die sie hinterlassen haben
dann halte ich das zumindest für zwar
alle erwachsenen zu verpflichten sich
zum schutz aller vor dieser krankheit
unter weiteren freiheits einschränkungen
zu impfen zu lassen
frau kollegin haben wir zu sagen haben
dieser stelle an die mitglieder der
unionsfraktion
verweigern sie sich nicht nutzen sie die
uneinigkeit der regierungskoalition in
dieser frage nicht für kurzfristige
parteipolitische
zeigen sie nun zur vereinfachung hat ihn
vorher aus den stationen gesehen
in der linksfraktion gibt es
unterschiedliche auffassungen was eine
impfung nicht an die puppen ja in der
version die bären hier vorgeschlagen
dass eine allgemeine art 18
monolithischen blöcke in dieser debatte
zumindest bislang erkennbar lediglich in
der unionsfraktion und in der kfd der
nächste redner ist
herbert wolle und er ist dafür in eine
garage ullmann und andré abweichend vom
meinem redest crypt 1 voraussagen was
ich gestern und vorgestern und heute an
medizinischen unsinn gehört habe das ist
hanebüchen
sehr geehrte damen und herren als arzt
für innere medizin der den letzten 30
jahren in der altmark ambulant und stadt
und stationär praktiziert hat werde ich
zwei dinge in meiner rede deutlich
machen
erstens was hat mich dazu gebracht
diesen 50 antrag mit einzubringen und
zweitens warum glaube ich das ist der
richtige weg ist um aus der aktuellen
situation hinaus zu kommen mir bleibt
der vierzehnte jander
2021 in besonderer erinnerung an diesem
von vielen menschen in meinem wahlkreis
verwey gesinnten tag habe ich erstmals
mit meinem praxisteam gegen kobe 19 gmt
der dezember davor also der dezember
mit vielen corona schwer kranken und
toten auch unter meinen patienten und
patientinnen war noch sehr präsent und
beeindruckt eine weitere grenzwertige
belastung unseres gesundheitssystems
darf es nicht mehr geben ihm bleibt das
beste mittel
der das bisher nicht begriffen hat
handelt verantwortungslos
wir wissen zwar dass sich das erstens
eine impfung die häufigkeit eines
schweren verlaufs signifikant reduziert
zweitens dass die nebenwirkungen der
impfungen vergleichbar mit denen anderer
impfungen sind und da muss sich der
abgeordnete der grünen weitgehend dieser
sprechen hier von geredet hat das war
wird nicht daneben
drittens
das ist eine altersabhängige häufung von
schweren gerät 19 erkrankungen gibt die
insbesondere ab dem fünfzigsten
lebensjahr zunehmend relevant wird das
ist ja auch der grund für unseren antrag
besonders der dritte punkt also die
alters abhängigkeit der komplikationen
führt in der pandemie zu einer starken
belastung unseres gesundheitssystems
daher heißt es bei uns erst beraten erst
noch mal alle beraten dann nimmt
kollegen
auch mal der ersten rede wenn es dann
sehr viel ist ich erinnere nur daran
dass ihre redezeit um ist ich bin
gut weiterhin auf 15
diese einschätzung die wir teilen in
ihrer stellungnahme auch die mitglieder
des deutschen ethikrates
an dem sich unser antrag weitgehend
orientierte die wahrung der
verhältnismäßigkeit
verpflichtet uns das mildeste mittel zu
werden
betrachtet man diese aspekte so ist
dieser proben für 50 die beste lösung
denn die höhere sind nicht die die unser
gesundheitssystem belasten
jetzt bin ich fertig und ich hoffe dass
wir unseren antrag weitgehend zugestimmt
da gehört und das war herbert ballmann
aus der spd-fraktion facharzt und
oberarzt in seinem bisherigen leben ist
ja gewesen das war seine erste rede und
sein erster satz war selten so viel
unfug über das impfen gehört wie heute
die nächste rednerin für die gruppe
während diese und andere also für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht 18 ist emilia
fester aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen ja
begonnen hat war ich 21 jahre alt
wissen sie noch was sie gemacht haben
hat die 21
ich habe es den ich habe innerhalb der
vergangenen zwei jahre aus vorsicht und
aus rücksicht das folgende nicht gemacht
ich war nicht in der uni
ich war nicht im ausland
ich habe kein museum und auch kein
festival besucht ich habe nicht mal eine
person die ich noch nicht kannte geküsst
oder meinen geburtstag gefeiert
ich höre verdacht auf meine ich einmal
im club tanzen feiern und all das was
ich so vermissen das mag ihn jetzt
vielleicht lächerlich vorkommen aber
wissen sie was wirklich lächerlich ist
wenn sie und ihre freundinnen der
freiheit sich einfach hätten impfen
lassen als die meisten von uns so
vernünftig waren in diesen einfachen
schritt gegangen sind dann dann wäre ich
jetzt wieder sein
dann werden wir alle wieder frei oder
zumindest so jahr um das zu machen was
wir lieben und worauf wir jetzt seit
zwei jahren warten was man sie von uns
depressiv macht menschen in die
einsamkeit stürzt und familien in den
wahnsinn treibt weil wir bereit sind
unsere freiheit für das leben anderer
menschen zu geben wo in der alle gruppen
zu schützen das war und das ist unsere
solidarität
aber
ich fordere jetzt den payback wir haben
nämlich das gefunden was uns schützen
kann und deshalb will ich meine freiheit
zurück ich will sie zurück
und ich will sie nicht nur kurzzeitig
zurück weil jetzt einige leute besonders
laut freedom day rufen
und offensichtlich alle erfahrungen mit
diesem virus die wir alle gemeinsam
gemacht haben ignorieren liebe fdp
fraktion nur weil man die pandemie für
beendet erklärt ist sie noch nicht
vorbei
ihre individuelle freiheit endet dort wo
meine beginnt wo die kollektive freiheit
verdient und diese persönliche
entscheidung sich nicht impfen zu lassen
beeinflusst mein leben beeinflusst das
leben von millionen von menschen in
dieser bundesrepublik nicht die
impfpflicht ist die zumutung sondern
keine impfpflicht ist die zumutung die
zumutung für die solidarische mehrheit
ich habe mich nicht um ein
bundestagsmandat beworben um im
bundestag dabei zuzusehen wie meine
generation in klimafragen angst um ihre
zukunft haben muss und parallel dazu in
der pandemie auch noch ihre gegenwart
verliert ihres heute ihren sport die
bewegung diese seien eben spaß am jung
sein das muss jetzt ein ende haben und
ich sag' das jetzt auch noch einmal ganz
deutlich es muss hier um die impfpflicht
für alle erwachsenen gehen nicht auf
irgend einer willkürlichen altersgrenze
denn alle menschen egal welchen alters
übertragen das virus stärker wenn sie
ungeimpft sind es reicht nicht mehr mit
kosmetischen eingriffen die schweren
verläufe zu drücken wir arbeiten hier an
der erden immunität und deswegen nehme
ich sie jetzt in die pflicht lassen sie
sich impfen für die kinder die
jugendlichen für unsere freiheit ich
kämpfe für die allgemeine impfpflicht ab
18 denn impfen darf kann in die
individuelle entscheidung mehr sein es
ist keine vielen dank
hier sind zurückhaltend
vom leben aber ich glaube das könnte man
schon eine wutrede von betafence paar
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
die sich für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ab 18 ausgesprochen hat nächste rednerin
wird sein simone borchert
im präsidium die leitung dieser sitzung
gewechselte petra portet die nächsten
zwei stunden und dann ist wieder katrin
göring eckardt ran
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
unsere
bundesgesundheitsminister möchte eine
impfpflicht einführen dabei sind sie
sich als regierungsparteien selbst sehr
uneinig das mittlerweile ganz
verschiedene anträge aus ihren reihen
gibt hier geht das spektrum vom
impfpflicht 18 bis endlich ab 50 oder
gar keine impfpflicht und hier sehen wir
sehr sehr deutlich dass es keine klare
und strategische ausrichtung der
jetzigen regierungsparteien gibt
und c rtl lauterbach sie werden ja gar
nicht müde immer wieder die hohen
inzidenz zahlen ins feld zu führen um
somit die impfpflicht durchzusetzen aber
auch in der wirtschaft trifft man keine
strategischen entscheidung nur anhand
einer kennzahl und ich möchte sie daher
bitten hier in zukunft auch den
schweregrad der erkrankung zu
berücksichtigen dieser ist gerade nicht
vorhanden und auch die hospitalisierung
zahlen sind gerade völlig unauffällig
ins identen alleine bilden die
pandemische entwicklung nicht
sachgerecht ab und verzerren das bild
auch in der bevölkerung und führen zu in
akzeptanz
der antrag der cdu csu so dafür dass wir
genau diese wichtigen zahlen im blick
behalten werden und bei bedarf dann
reagieren können
außerdem ist aufgrund der impfung sowie
der schon erfolgten infektionen der
immunschutz in der bevölkerung weitaus
höher da hilft es auch nicht den
genesenen status einfach mal so zu
verändern kollege gold ort gestorben sie
eine frau oder bemerkung der kollegin
vogel wir sie gern
frau kollegin beuchert ich habe einst
bei ihrem antrag beim antrag ihrer
fraktion und auch bei ihrem vortrag
jetzt immer noch nicht verstanden
der cdu csu ist doch auch bewusst sein
dass bis zum erreichen des vollen
impfschutz mindestens drei impfungen mit
jeweils einem abstand von drei bis vier
fünf sechs monaten erforderlich sind und
insofern
insofern frage ich sie ob es wirklich
eine kluge idee ist mit dem einsetzen
einer impfpflicht zu warten bis eine
neue sehr gefährliche möglicherweise
tödliche variante sich gebildet hat und
sich in deutschland verbreitet wie
wollen sie dem denn dann entgegentreten
könnten
vielen dank für ihre frage aber es hilft
auch nicht können wir immer sagen was
wäre wenn
und deshalb denke ich dass die dass
dieses gesetz zur info sorge das einzig
richtige ist weil wenn wir uns an den
richtigen fakten orientieren wollen dann
orientierte und an incident zahlen an
der schwere der erkrankung an den
hospitalisierungen und
da komme ich gleich noch drauf auf die
inhalte auf 1 im free gestern und das
ist der einzig richtige weg woher wollen
wir den wissen jetzt ohne imf register
wer wann und wie oft geimpft ist
wir halten zum jetzigen zeitpunkt eine
impfpflicht unter den aktuellen
gegebenheiten für nicht zielführend
die korona pandemie stellt uns vor
herausforderungen und wir müssen unser
gesundheitssystem flexibel und
reaktionsfähig halten und aus diesem
grund hat die cdu csu fraktion den
antrag auf einem vorsorge gesetz
gestellt und hier liegen für uns die
zentralen punkte in einem register und
wenn ich höre immer dass gesprochen wird
von einer geringen impfquote dann frage
ich mich wo haben wir diese daten allein
das mit einem im kredite wären die
transparent und hätten eine gute
datengrundlage
die cdu csu möchte eine gute
impfkampagne und bei bedarf natürlich
ein impf mechanismus der greift wenn es
notwendig ist
in den jahren der pandemie haben wir
dazugelernt und dieses wissen müssen wir
jetzt nutzen um uns für die zukunft
aufzustellen und die rahmenbedingungen
der politik verändern sich im zuge der
entwicklung der pandemie ständig aber
sehr geehrter herr minister und auch
herr beck sie blenden die verändernden
rahmenbedingungen für mich komplett aus
und wir fordern hier mehr wissenschaft
mehr flexibilität und weniger stars in
vielen dank
simone borchert noch mit
wir haben hier eine debatte zu gruppen
und fraktions anträgen und alle haben
das recht auch redebeiträge zu protokoll
zu geben ich bin aber auch gehalten
dafür zu sorgen dass einerseits das
fragerecht
stattfinden kann aber nicht die
redebeiträge sich verdoppeln oder
verdreifachen
deshalb lasse ich in der regel oder
fraglich in der regel ob eine frage oder
bemerkungen zugelassen wird innerhalb
einer rede zwischen einer minute und
drei minuten aber nicht eine zweite und
dritte jeder hat ja die chance seine
beiträge oder meinungsäußerungen auch
noch zu protokoll zu geben
nun also dass eine anmerkung zum
sitzungsverlauf und
bundestagsvizepräsidentin petra pau die
sich den ganzen tag und den morgigen
auch hier in der leitung des bundestages
sind die aufgabe teilt mit katrin göring
eckardt drei vize bzw auch die
bundestagspräsidentin sind anprobiert 19
erkrankt eine viertel
vizepräsident denen ist einfach so
krankheit ich etwas gesagt aber das ist
ja auch nicht besser
k wie mansouri ist am pult für die
spd-fraktion mit dem rechtsausschuss und
er unterstützt den antrag von die remise
und heike behrens zb also die in 8 16
schwere verläufe überlastung der
krankenhäuser patientinnen und patienten
die auf behandlung warten müssen
einschränkungen des öffentlichen und
privaten lebens in den kitas und schulen
in den betrieben in der kultur
gastronomie und im sport und menschen
die unnötig sterben werden ich finde das
sind die schlechteren alternativen
und wenn ich als und wenn ich als anwalt
hinzufügen darf sie sind auch nicht
grundrecht schonender seit zwei jahren
erleben jetzt eine endlos spirale aus
infektionswellen und schutzmaßnahmen das
land ist müde davon eltern die keine
planbarkeit haben pflegekräfte die am
ende sind und nicht mehr können diese
spirale muss enden der freiheits
beschränkende maßnahmen im herbst
verhindern will der muss die impfquote
jetzt erhöhen und nicht erst im herbst
mal die damen und herren
sie beginn der pandemie
da war wenig über das virus und das
infektionsgeschehen bekannt aber wie
viele wellen braucht es dennoch um eine
allgemeine impfpflicht zu regeln und wie
viel solidarität wollen sie dennoch von
kindern und jugendlichen von jungen
menschen ab verlangen die sich seit zwei
jahren einschränken um andere menschen
in diesem land zu schützen ich finde das
muss jetzt aufhören meine damen und
herren und ich will meinen teil ziehe
daraus auch konsequenzen für mein
politisches handeln und ich will hier
auch einräumen dass ich meine haltung
gegenüber einer allgemein impfnachweis
pflicht geändert habe ich finde das
zeichnet eine demokratische debatte aus
denn wir wollen hier keine glaubenssätze
austauschen sondern argumente auf der
basis von fakten und wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen wenn die sachlage sich
ändern muss auch die schlussfolgerung
deswegen will ich drei erkenntnisse
nennen erstens dass eine impfung
zuverlässig vor einer schwerwiegenden
erkrankung schützt ist erwiesen zweitens
erwiesen ist dass eine vorerkrankung
nicht denselben schutz vor wieder
ansteckung bietet wie eine
grundimmunisierung
durchimpfung drittens es gibt
mittlerweile varianten von cobit die
sich so schnell ausbreiten dass selbst
junge menschen sich auf den
intensivstationen finden obwohl sie ein
geringeres risiko haben schwerwiegend zu
erkranken und diese fakten gilt es zu
berücksichtigen wenn wir jetzt über das
für und wider einer allgemeinen endlich
diskutieren und über die ausgestaltung
ich für meinen teil halte den
gesetzesentwurf für die einführung einer
allgemeinen impfnachweis pflicht ab 18
für vorausschauend und richtig vor allem
bin ich davon überzeugt dass er zeitlich
befristet und beschränkt auf drei
impfungen auch verfassungsgemäß ist denn
unser grundgesetz verlangt von einer
staatlichen maßnahme dass sie einen
legitimen zweck verfolgt geeignet
erforderlich und angemessen ist um
dieses ziel zu erreichen über den
legitimen zweck und die geeignetheit zur
zweck erreichen dürfte hier kein
ernsthafter dissens bestehen sondern die
debatte dreht sich vor allem um die
erforderlichkeit und angemessenheit
eines verpflichtenden impfnachweis unter
sprechen die besseren argumente und
darauf komme ich gleich für den
gesetzesentwurf
manche wände nein keine impfnachweis
pflicht oder eine für teile der
bevölkerung sein
milder schon darüber kann man streiten
aber es ist eben nicht gleich geeignet
um unsere krankenhäuser im herbst und
unsere allgemeine freiheit zu schützen
und deswegen ist der gesetzesentwurf
nicht unterstütze auch erforderlich
und natürlich greift ein verpflichtender
impfnachweis in die grundrechte der
menschen ein aber grundrechts güter
gelten eben nicht uneingeschränkt
sondern sie sind in ein verhältnis
zueinander zu bringen deswegen muss man
auch hier feststellen ja jeder hat das
recht sich unvernünftig zu verhalten
aber dieses recht endet wo millionen
andere jahrelang in ihrer freiheit und
lebensweise eingeschränkt werden
zeitlich befristet und beschränkt auf
drei impfungen ist die nachweislich
zumutbar deswegen ist der
gesetzesentwurf auch angemessen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen 6 millionen
menschen sind mittlerweile an cobit
verstorben auch meine tante ich will in
keiner gesellschaft leben in der korona
tote einkalkuliert sind die im
nachweispflicht 18 weist einen weg aus
der pandemie gehen sie in büttel mit
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
da wir mansouri war dass er noch mal
deutlich gemacht hat warum er für die
impfpflicht ab 18 ist also für den
gesetzentwurf der hierunter behrendt und
andere läuft gelegentlich auch unter
wiese und dann drauf janosch dahmen hat
sich für diese variante ausgesprochen
aus der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
und wir schauen nun wieder in die
installation günter krings ist
rechtspolitischer sprecher und
jetzt am pult
auch die heutige debatte hat uns eine
entscheidung über das ob das wie eine
impfpflicht nicht wirklich näher
gebracht und der wichtigste grund ist
offensichtlich dass sie noch immer in
der tiefe zerrissenheit bei diesem thema
sind innerhalb der ampel koalition und
die versteckten das hinter gruppen
anträgen das kann man machen aber es ist
eben die folge aber mit der dramatischen
weltpolitischen lage schwindet schwindet
endgültig das verständnis für diesen
advent ismus der bundesregierung in
dieser zentralen innenpolitischen fragen
und offensichtlich durchzieht diese
zerrissenheit in ihrer koalition ja die
gesamte corona politik das andere
prominente beispiel die sitzungswoche
ist die novellierung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
die verbände hatten hier für ihre
beteiligung und stellungnahme knapp neun
stunden in der nacht und im text nehmen
sie den ländern fast alle
handlungsmöglichkeiten zur pandemie
bekämpfung und das alles bei extrem
steigenden ansteckungszahlen ein
ministerpräsident der spd wurde merkt
sprach davon man werfe hier den
feuerlöscher mitten im brandt weg mal
damen und herren
ich weiß auch nicht ob er schon dankbar
sein sollen dass sie es überhaupt
infektionsschutzgesetz zu einem
regierungsentwurf gebracht haben und
nicht uns auch damit gruppen anträgen
konfrontiert habe meine damen und herren
aber wie passt das jetzt eigentlich
zusammen wenn die ampel mehrheit die
meisten schutzmaßnahmen schleift und
eine große mehrheit innerhalb der ampel
zugleich eine sofortige im pflicht
einführen will hat den eindruck bei
diesen beiden themen bewegen sich in
zwei parallel universum meine damen und
herren
deshalb mein appell jedenfalls war der
impfpflicht wäre es doch gut wenn sie
ausnahmsweise auf die stimme der
vernunft hören und die besagt erster in
der jetzigen omikron welle käme die
einführung eine allgemeine impfpflicht
schlichtweg zu spät und zweitens dass
die anordnung einer impfpflicht die dann
im herbst gegen eine neue virusvariante
wirken soll zumindest eben heute noch
nicht zu rechtfertigen ist ja impfen ist
der zentrale weg aus der pandemie und
dennoch ist die pflicht zur impfung ein
grundrechtseingriff und er lässt sich
eben nur rechtfertigen mit der
überlastung des gesundheitssystems dass
wir das verhindern wollen dass sich eine
pflicht zur impfung dann nur auf die
jetzt verfügbaren impfstoffe beziehen
kann deren wirkung auf künftiger
varianten wir noch gar nicht kennen
können das führt dazu dass eben die
geeignetheit nicht gegeben ist
verfassungsrechtlich und bei
entscheidungen unter unsicherheit darf
der gesetzgeber auch nicht voreilig
entscheiden sondern muss zunächst die
verfügbaren erkenntnisse zusammen trag-
und sachgerecht bewerten genau das
fordern wir bis dahin ist eben eine
impfpflicht auch nicht erforderlich im
sinne des verfassungsrechts meine damen
und herren
sehr wohl erforderlich ist aber dass
bund länder und kommunen jetzt ihre
hausaufgaben machen und die
vorbereitungen für eine möglicherweise
später notwendige impfpflicht treffen
das reicht von der stärkung der
infrastruktur
bis hin zum aufbau eines nationalen im
freezers was wir jetzt brauchen ist also
keine impfpflicht auf vorrat sondern ein
vorsorge gesetz meine damen und herren
und auch das kann ich nicht ersparen
bleibt die vorlage eines solchen
gesetzes oder eines solchen
gesetzentwurf ist natürlich die
ureigenste aufgabe der bundesregierung
dafür gibt es sie meine damen und herren
in einer zentralen frage
innerhalb der größten krise der
nachkriegszeit in politischer hinsicht
muss die bundesregierung sich endlich
ihrer verantwortung stellen weil damit
und sie wäre klug beraten wenn sie dabei
unserem zwei stufen modell folgt aus
sachlichen und verfassungsrechtlichen
gründen aber auch weil es der einzig
realistische weg ist der uns die
sinnvolle option nicht mehr nicht
weniger die sinnvolle option für eine
impfpflicht erhält ich fordere daher die
regierung auf legen sie einen
regierungsentwurf für tim vorsorge
gesetz zügig vor und die probleme mit
der bisherigen berufsbezogenen
impfpflicht das rudern in österreich das
zeigt doch es reicht doch nicht einfach
eine impfpflicht anzuordnen wenn dann
muss sie auch gut vorbereitet sein mal
da muss an vielen dank
günter krings war das für die
unionsfraktionen der hier nochmal
juristische und auch verfassungs aspekte
eingeworfen hatten die diskussion und
sie haben gesehen möglicherweise schon
unser bild im bild wie wir das nennen
wir erwarten in kürze eine
pressekonferenz vom bundeskanzler scholz
mit nato-generalsekretärs deutenberg vor
ihren gesprächen heute und wenn die
beginnt gehen wir natürlich live auf
dieses signal auch in pflicht debatte im
bundestag mit katrin göring eckardt
sie zweifeln hier daran dass das
parlament wir als parlament nicht
selbstbewusst genug ist gemeinsam eine
entscheidung in einer so wichtigen frage
zu treffen das verstehe ich nicht
zweiter darauf den sternen
wir haben werde seit zwei jahren können
nicht zwei jahre lang hat die ampel
koalition hier miteinander regiert am
anfang der pandemie haben wir als
bündnis 90 die grünen auch andere
fraktionen immer wieder gesagt ja wir
machen das hier im parlament gemeinsam
gestützt in einem posting wir gemeinsam
entwickelt haben unabhängig davon
welcher fraktion oder welcher partei sie
angehören in dieser frage bleibt und ist
das zentral dass wir hier als parlament
gemeinsam in einem vernünftigen forum
ist eine gute lösung finden das sage ich
bevor ich begründet warum ich würde es
nicht 18
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nicht dass kollegen krings es soll sein
obwohl ich weiß dass ich selbst
vielen dank frau kollegin da ziemlich
angesprochen haben wollte ich gerne
darauf auch mit einer frage werden sie
haben kritisiert dass ich kritisiere
dass es keinen regierungsentwurf gibt
sind sie bereits zur kenntnis zu nehmen
dadurch sehr wohl der auffassung mit
ihnen bin dass nur diese entscheidung im
pflicht ja nein oder wie und in welchem
modell natürlich nur hier im bundestag
für uns als abgetreten ist das über die
regierung in der pflicht steht in dieser
zentralen frage einen regierungsentwurf
zu machen und erlauben sie mir zugleich
dass ich daran erinnere dass wir bei dem
thema einer berufsbezogenen pflicht auch
keine gruppenanträge haben und damit
verbinde ich die frage sind sie der
auffassung dass krankenpfleger ärztinnen
und ärzte dass deren grundrechte weniger
relevant sind das also da ein
regierungsentwurf geht und ansonsten wie
aber gruppenanträge machen müssen aus
gründen der sensibilität der grundrecht
sensibilität worin liegt der unterschied
ich beginne mit dem mit den zweiten
reihe mich das auch sehr umtreibt
nämlich die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht und dass viele der menschen
die dort arbeiten das gefühl haben wieso
wir uns nicht alle anderen mich bringt
das dazu dass ich die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht da habe ich auch
meine meinung geändert in den letzten
wochen monaten dass die einrichtungs
bezogen im pflicht der erste schritt ist
zu einer allgemeinen endlich darum geht
es und so ihrer zweiten frage herr
krings man kann jetzt auch noch weiter
ich weiß nicht wie lange wochen lang
über das verfahren reden mir wäre
wichtig dass wir über die sache reden
und eine entscheidung das ist sagt
voraus
und deswegen sagen jetzt habe meine
meinung geändert ich dachte es geht
einfach nicht und es geht mit
niedrigeren quoten das war ja bei
anderen varianten auch der fall das ist
jetzt nicht mehr so die welt hat sich
dramatisch verändert aber eines ist
geblieben nämlich corona das virus ist
mitnichten verschwunden im gegenteil die
infektionszahlen sind so hoch wie nie
kein tag vergeht an dem sich eine
tochter partnerin partner
arbeitskollegen gute freundin davon
berichtet dass es jetzt zwei striche
sind auf dem schnelltest corinna trifft
familien wie schulen krankenhäuser wie
wirtschaft und ja auch unser parlament
und insbesondere im sinne der kinder
müssen wir jetzt endlich dafür sorgen
dass wir diese pandemie dieses auf und
ab dieses hin und her dieses mal noch
tausendmal freiheit dieses mal maßnahmen
und mal keine mehr endlich beenden und
wir haben dieses eine scharfen schwert
noch in der hand dieses eine scharfe
schwert ist die allgemeine impfpflicht
und ich rufe sie auf mit und dafür zu
sorgen dass wir in diesem land die
freiheit zurückgewinnen denn genau darum
geht es ich will
ich rede nein es geht nicht um freiheit
durch zwang sondern es geht darum dass
eine minderheit nicht diktieren kann wie
eine mehrheit in diesem land lebt und
wir haben wir haben wirklich alles daran
gesetzt dass das impfen freiwillig
passieren kann und jeder wird sagen
manche kampagne hätte besser und schicke
und ich weiß nicht was sein können aber
inzwischen bald jede und jeder das
impfen schützt und dass jede und jeder
weiß ich habe eine verantwortung kann
sie wahrnehmen oder nicht und für
diejenigen die sie bisher nicht
wahrgenommen haben da gibt es welche die
haben ernsthafte bedenken sorgen manche
können es übrigens nicht manche können
es nicht und es gibt menschen die in
diesem land seit zwei jahren kaum
politur gehen können auch für die müssen
wir sagt im allgemeinen und zuletzt
meine damen und herren sind ich sagen es
gibt hier einige besonders lieben
dastehende denen die allgemeine
impfpflicht das impfen überhaupt immer
ein riesen problem war für die wird es
jetzt ein bisschen einfacher da gibt es
nämlich eine anweisung und dann muss man
das machen und auch damit glaube ich
sind wir ganz gut aufgehoben ich bin für
die allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 für
alle erwachsenen das ist der weg und
gerne reden wir über alle anderen
verfassungsgemäßen varianten damit wir
hier gemeinsam zu einer guten
entscheidung komme herzlichen dank
katrin göring-eckardt für einen uns
nicht aus 18 weil so sagt sie eine
minderheit nicht diktieren darf wie die
mehrheit lebt und deshalb ist sie wie
gesagt für den antrag von heike behrens
die akquise janosch dahmen und anderen
bis das bei der im vorletzten redner in
dieser debatte matthias keller
der bundesgesundheitsminister dr karl
lauterbach dem russischen
staatspräsidenten per ferndiagnose eine
narzisstische persönlichkeitsstörung
da ich mir eine ähnliche
psychoanalytische fachkompetenz wie er
bundesgesundheitsminister zutraue
erlaube ich mir nun mal eine
ferndiagnose
das münchhausen beim proxy syndrom ist
eine sonderform der artifiziellen
störung bei der physisch gesunde
personen bei einem anderen menschen
häufig dem eigenen kind krank alten
vortäuschen oder bewusst herbeiführen um
anschließend eine medizinische
behandlung zu verlangen der täter macht
das opfer krank und dadurch anerkennung
und aufmerksamkeit zu erlangen auch wenn
keine gefährdung für das opfer durch
eine krankheit besteht treibt es der
täter in zahlreiche medizinische
behandlung erkennen sie das
krankheitsbild und möglicherweise den
erkrankten herr doktor lauterbach obwohl
inzwischen zahlreiche echte experten
eine allgemeine impfpflicht ablehnen
wird der bundesgesundheitsminister samt
seiner jünger nicht müde diese immer und
immer wieder lautstark zu fordern
gewichtige stimmen wie die von den
professoren cullen strikt kekulé oder
stört die eine allgemeine impfpflicht
gegen das koma virus sowohl medizinisch
als auch juristisch ablehnen werden
ignoriert weil es ihnen ja längst gar
nicht mehr um gesundheitspolitik in
diesem land geht sie wissen dass sie und
ihre warnung ihr wirken als mächtige
dressur elite mit dem auftauchen von
omikron beendet sind omikron macht das
virus schwach omikron macht aber auch
sie schwach und nach zwei jahren der
angst politik haben sie angst angst vor
dem bedeutungsverlust sie haben nun eine
chance sich an einen heilungsprozess in
unserem land unser verletzten
gesellschaft zu beteiligen indem sie die
menschen endlich in ruhe lassen und
ihnen ihre freiheit vollumfänglich
zurück geben stimmen sie daher gegen
jede form des im zwangs und beenden sie
die herrschaft des münchhausen
stellvertreter syndrom es in der
bundesdeutschen
gesundheitspolitik vielen dank
matthias helferich war das in
argumentation und wortwahl erkennbar als
hfd mitglied im bundestag fraktionslos
unter anderem weil er sich einmal selbst
als das freundliche gesicht des
nationalsozialismus bezeichnet hat und
weil er auch jena hat der partei unter
radikalismus verdacht steht also ist er
hier nicht mehr mitglied der fraktion
aber natürlich noch mitglied der partei
karl lauterbach der
bundesgesundheitsminister ist der letzte
redner in dieser debatte hoffen wir dass
wir in komplett hinkriegen und
aus meiner sicht gute debatte gehabt es
gab ein paar tiefpunkt es gab auch sehr
gute beiträge wo stehen wir jetzt na ja
wir müssen uns vor augen führen das hat
sich nicht viel verändert wir haben die
fünf szenarien vor uns die im herbst
kommen können was christian drosten
beschrieben hat in seiner ausarbeitung
auch für mitglieder des bundestags dass
wir im herbst vielleicht möglicherweise
wieder eine mikrowelle bekommen dass wir
vielleicht eine dieser varianten
welle bekommen weil derzeit die
impfquote in afrika nur 14 prozent ist
und dort sehr viel dass ich wieder
ausbreitet wir können und relevanter
entfernte variante bekommen wir können
eine delta cohen kombinations variante
bekommen und was sehr gefährlich wäre
und nicht unwahrscheinlich ist dass sich
omikron weiterentwickelt und einfach
tiefer in die lunge eindringt mal das
sind nur ganz wenige mutationen die das
derzeit verhindern die können jederzeit
verloren
gestatten sie eine frage oder
bemerkungen des abgeordneten brandner
nein auf keinen fall die
die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir eine dieser
varianten sehen geht an fast 100 prozent
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir im
herbst keine schwierigkeiten haben die
bewohner pandemie zu bekämpfen liegt bei
fast null prozent
das ist fast so wahrscheinlich aus dass
wir gar keinen herbst bekämen daher wir
müssen uns vorbereiten was wird also im
herbst auf uns zukommen im herbst werden
wir erneut die frage stellen müssen wird
unser gesundheitssystem überlastet sein
was können wir tun um diese überlastung
begeht zu begegnen was müssen wir
schließen wie gehen wir mit den
geschäften um was können wir unseren
kindern erneut zumuten es sind die
pflegekräfte da die wir können ja nicht
die vielen ungeimpften die dank
behandlungen benötigen uns ja auch
bekommen werden dann können wir ja nicht
sagen ihr hättet euch ja impfen lassen
können wir behandeln uns nicht wir sind
eine zivilisierte gesellschaft das heißt
wir werden diese menschen die zum teil
selbstschutz hin zum größten teil sogar
sehr wir werden sie wandeln müssen und
dann wird erneut das ganze land in der
geiselhaft dieser gruppe von menschen
sagt die sich einfach gegen die
wissenschaftliche evidenz der weltweiten
vorschau der weltweiten behandlungs
forscher im forscher durchsetzen die im
prinzip noch stolz darauf sind dass das
land auf sie wartet ob sie sich impfen
lassen oder nicht das können wir uns aus
meiner sicht nicht mehr lassen wir
müssen berücksichtigen auf die kinder
wir müssen muss ich dem auch die
pflegekräfte wir müssen rücksicht nehmen
auf diejenigen die um ihre existenz
jetzt geht es darum dass mal diejenigen
die regeln beachten dieses all die zeit
nicht getan habt da kann man natürlich
die frage stellen wirken die impfungen
überhaupt oder nicht das wissen wir doch
wir wissen dass all die varianten sehen
wir nicht gerade aufgesetzten gezählt
habe all diese varianten sind genetisch
zu weit über 90 prozent identisch daher
wirken noch alle impfstoffe die zwei
jahre alten johann impfstoffe verhindern
nach wie vor schwere krankheit und tod
natürlich verhindern sie nicht in jedem
fall die ansteckung kolleg haben wir das
problem der ansteckung ist ja nicht das
hauptproblem wenn wir nicht schwer krank
werden oder sterben es geht doch hier
darum schwere krankheit und tod zu
verhindern und dafür haben wir die
impfstoffe den idealen setzen und ich
komme auf die vorschläge des juniors
links hat ja gesagt pack links hatte hat
ganz klar darauf hingewiesen es stimmt
die impfpflicht kommt zu spät für die
omnicom müller das ist wichtig aber ihr
eigener vorschlag der würde doch dafür
sorgen dass die impfpflicht für jede
weitere wenn er die noch gestellt und
ihr wunschland ist doch der vorschlag
dass wir ehrliche satz wichtige zeichen
jetzt mit kommen nicht weiter und ich
glaube laudenbach eine letzte frage
gestatten sie haben fragen oder
bemerkungen der kollegin vogel das würde
ich machen
ja ich würde sagen die eine zugelassene
von der präsidentin erlaubt dazwischen
frage gut eingeteilt vielen dank herr
kollege laut aber
mir ist ein bisschen auf wir sind ja
gemeinsam unterwegs für dieses thema
impfen ich habe 18 aber mir ist schon
ein bisschen aufgestoßen dass sie das so
sehr individualisieren müssten wenn ich
auch ein bisschen demütiger darauf
gucken was die politik in diesen letzten
zwei jahren falsch gemacht hat
unterlassen hat nicht hinreichend auf
den weg gebracht hat um den menschen das
vertrauen zu geben dass diese empfehlung
die wir ihnen geben und das wird so wir
sie auffordern dass sie sich bitte bitte
alle drei mal impfen lassen sollen das
auch wirklich umzusetzen müssen also mir
widerstrebt es einfach darauf diese
diese individualisierte
schuldzuweisungen zu machen ich glaube
wir haben sie auch mit
gesellschaftlichen prozessen zu tun und
wir müssen nach der pandemie oder nach
dem was wir jetzt alles entscheidend
dringend darüber reden unser
gesundheitswesen solidarische und
gerechte aufzustellen damit die menschen
auch wieder mehr vertrauen haben
vielen dank dass sie haben recht schuld
zulassungen sind fehl am platz aber
verantwortungs zuweisungen sind richtig
und die ungeimpften tragen derzeit die
verantwortung dafür dass wir nicht
weiterkommen und das muss man sagen
dürfen das ist auch nicht und im übrigen
wir müssen noch nach vorne blicken
natürlich sind auch fehler gemacht
worden natürlich sind auch fehler
gemacht worden aber wo stehen wir denn
jetzt wir sind jetzt zum ersten mal 20
22 ist das erste jahr wo wir tatsächlich
die pandemie für deutschland leider
nicht weltweit aber wir können die
pandemie für deutschland zum ersten mal
beendet mit der impfung mit dem pflicht
lassen wir uns auch diese gelegenheit
ergreift und wir haben sie jetzt
wenn ja meine damen und herren wer ist
dass krieg schneck corona wenn man so
will und der kasseler den minister
deswegen verlassen wir vorübergehend den
deutschen bundestag gehen rüber ins
kanzleramt der bundeskanzler mit
nato-generalsekretär jens stoltenberg
und wenn sie da zu hören wollen bei
youtube machen wir weiter mit der
debatte
nicht müssen wir nicht angst haben dann
kommen wir durch dann müssen wir nicht
erneut in dieser endlosschleife zurück
diese gelegenheit haben wir heute und
ich appelliere an alle demokratischen
parteien bitte erlauben sie hier ihren
abgeordneten gewissensentscheidung ich
weiß dass überall in allen parteien
fehle es so sehen wir haben diese
gelegenheit daher werden wir hier über
eine ganz wichtige entscheidung treffen
bestehen im herbst an der gleichen
stelle wie jetzt wenn wir diese
einmalige chance nicht gemeinsame kaufen
[Applaus]
bevor ich die aussprache schließe bitte
ich darum sowohl bei verbalen äußerungen
als auch bei nonverbal
meinungsäußerungen sich einer
parlamentarischen ausdrucksweise zu
befleißigen ich will jetzt nicht
beschreiben was ich von hier vorne alles
sehen musste und hören musste ich
schließe die aussprache
interfraktionell gut überweisung der
vorlagen auf den drucksachen
978 und 516 an die in der tagesordnung
aufgeführten ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere überweisungs vorschläge
das ist nicht der fall dann verfahren
wir wie vorgeschlagen
ein kleiner hinweis den meine kollegin
katrin göring eckardt heute früh auch
schon gegeben hat und gestern zum beginn
unserer beratung sie wissen dass sie bis
morgen nachmittag mit der kollegin
göring eckardt und mir hier vorlieb
nehmen müssen
daraus folgt dass wir natürlich wenn
fragen oder bemerkungen angemeldet
werden die redner befragen ob sie diese
zu lassen wir lassen prinzipiell aber
keine kurzintervention nach den reden zu
es sei denn es ist durch die
geschäftsordnung geboten weil jemand
persönlich in irgendeiner weise
angegriffen wurde das zum weiteren
fortgang
unserer gemeinsamen arbeit ich rufe auf
den tagesordnungspunkt 7
beratungsinstanz eintrag aus der
unionsfraktion in dem es so
sichere energieversorgung geht
eigentlich sollte ihnen dieser
aussprache auch reden der saarländische
ministerpräsident
tobias hans aber genauso wie
bundestagspräsident in bars wie
vizepräsident kubicki wie vizepräsident
in einer analyse von corona heimgesucht
und deshalb nicht in der lage hier im
parlament zu reden gibt es wohl den
umständen entsprechend gut aber sie
müssen natürlich
sicherheitshalber zu hause bleiben und
können dann mit veranstaltungen wie hier
nicht teilnehmen sie umgesehen
vielleicht auch der bundestag hat die
sitze etwas enger zusammenrücken
gelassen die abstände sind nicht mehr so
wie das noch vor kurzem war jens spahn
ist der erste redner für diesen unions
kind auch gestern und heute wieder
zivile ziele bombardiert
das ist barbarisch das schicksal der
ukraine bewegt uns tief im kampf um
freiheit und sicherheit ja ums nackte
überleben
deswegen trifft und seine verantwortung
in diesem konflikt uns zu positionieren
gegen den aggressor putin und zur
ukraine und ihrem präsidenten sie lenski
es wäre gut gewesen es wäre gut gewesen
wenn sich die bundesregierung hier nach
der rede des präsidenten
erklärt hätte wie sie zu seinen worten
und auch forderungen steht und wenn
dieses parlament darüber hier im
anschluss debattiert hätte dazu waren
sie nicht bereit dies bedauern wir
ausdrücklich
nun debattieren wir dank unseres antrags
wenigstens über einen teilbereich in dem
es gilt in diesem krieg unsere eigenen
deutschen und europäischen interessen zu
formulieren und verantwortung zu
übernehmen wir müssen so schnell wie
möglich putin frei werden in unserer
energieversorgung deutschland braucht
eine sichere und souveräne
energieversorgung wir können nicht
leugnen wir haben uns in eine situation
zu große abhängigkeit begeben als als
einziges industrieland der welt steigen
wir gleichzeitig aus kohle und
kernenergie aus und versuchen
währenddessen
versorgungssicherheit bezahlbarkeit und
klimaneutralität bis 2010 und 40 zu
gewährleisten auf diesem weg zur
energiewende sollte gas noch über viele
jahre die brückentechnologie bilden und
russland als lieferant von möglichst
vielen günstigen gas diesen putins
invasion erschüttert das fundament
dieser brücke in ihren grundfesten ich
möchte klar dabei sagen wir müssen
anerkennen als demokratische parteien in
diesem parlament dass wir nahezu alle
den weg diese energie wende bei
gleichzeitigem doppelten ausstieg
gegangen sind und und die mitgetragen
haben und ja dass man manche
entscheidung heute und ja
beruhigend
beruhigen sie sich
und dass manche entscheidungen man heute
anders treffen würde deswegen will ich
auch ausdrücklich
ganz ruhig ganz ruhig
deswegen will ich auch ausdrücklich das
was sie herr minister habe
das was er minister habe auch in der
korrektur viele eigene positionen gesagt
und angestoßen haben anerkennen und
unterstützen
wir fordern in unserem antrag an
schlüssigen plan der bundesregierung zur
sicherstellung der energieversorgung
insbesondere der gas- und
stromversorgung der umfassende plan der
bundesregierung muss drei
unterschiedliche komponenten
berücksichtigen was ist wenn russland
morgen am tag seinerseits alle
lieferungen und kürzungen kürzt oder
stoppt was bedeutet das für deutschland
für die bürgerinnen und bürger die
industrie wie können wir ein ende der
gasimporte über nord stream 1
ermöglichen die werden wir spätestens
bis zum winter 2023 24 unabhängig von
russischen importen
wer unter diesen voraussetzungen kurz
mittel und langfristig die
energieversorgung sicherstellen möchte
die zarte entscheidungen treffen müssen
und er muss die grundlegend herleiten
und erklären und deswegen der minister
habe beck ist es gut dass ich heute hier
zu impfpflicht gesprochen haben aber ich
jetzt noch besser gefunden wenn sie zu
diesem thema heute hier im deutschen
bundestag auch was sagen wenn einmal
mehr sagt die bundesregierung nichts zu
einem entscheidenden thema für
deutschland nein dass zeugen ihre
kollegin und kollegen das ist doch
mittlerweile muster hier im deutschen
bundestag war jetzt wird gerade eine
pressekonferenz gegeben des
bundeskanzlers wo er sich wahrscheinlich
zur rede von sie nancy verhält es geht
doch so nicht dass wir im deutschen
bundestag die bundesregierung sich nicht
verhält zu vielen wichtigen fragen aber
ständig draußen irgendwo interviews gibt
so funktioniert das nicht
dazu ich war in jeder debatte überhaupt
kein thema dazu zählen auch schnelle
entscheidungen bei der kohle kohle
importe zu diversifizieren und
kohlekraftwerke auch aus der reserve zu
holen jeder tag den die ampel bei
aktivierung von kohlekraftwerken zögert
gefährdert die energieversorgung im
nächsten winter denn aktive
kohlekraftwerke tragen dazu bei dass
jetzt die gasspeicher auch schneller
gefüllt werden können dazu gehört auch
eine umfassende prüfung in sachen
kernenergie und weiterbetrieb der
kernkraftwerke
wer jetzt schon wer jetzt schon
ideologisch möglichkeiten ausschließt
ohne lösungen gefunden hatten zu haben
handelt der lage nicht angemessen und es
ist auch nicht gut im sinne der co2
neutralität wenn wir die energieform die
co2 neutrale daraus die erst kurz und
ganz schnell wir sind wieder zurück
geben im bundestag wo es um einen antrag
der unionsfraktionen dreht zu sichere
und bezahlbare energieversorgung zur
begründung des antrags der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
unionsfraktion jens spahn wir
unterstützen insoweit alle diese
bemühungen bei all dem darf die
bundesregierung keine falschen
vorstellungen verbinden wir brauchen
kurzfristige lösungen und putin frei zu
werden in unserer energieversorgung
zähle ich dazu bei und vor allem braucht
es entschlossenheit auch in der
umsetzung pipelines leitung terminals
die bauen sich eben nicht nur durch
erklärungen sondern wären wir jetzt vor
allem die regierung auch mit nachdruck
dran bleibt ein letztes ein wichtiges
thema rente und geschlossenheit filter
koalition ganz offensichtlich auch bei
den hohen energiepreisen deswegen vorab
wir begrüßen es dass die bundesregierung
nunmehr einige der forderungen die wir
hier vor einem monat erhoben haben auch
umsetzt das haben sie noch alles
abgewehrt heute tun sie ist gut so aber
leider viel zu spät
wir begrüßen es dass sie eine
regelrechte kehrtwende hier hinlegen
jetzt soll es angesichts der steigenden
spritpreise die der finanzminister eine
entlastung noch ausgeschlossen hat vor
einer woche doch eine entlastung gehen
mindestens unter deutlich zwei euro das
hat er gesagt an dieser ankündigung
werden wir die bundesregierung messen
bevor die koalition eigene vorschläge
auf den tisch gelegt hat arbeitet sie
sich an unseren vorschlägen ab seit
tagen das ist okay aber zur wahrheit
gehört eben auch dass die wählerinnen
und wähler ihnen einen regierungsauftrag
gegeben haben und nicht uns und deswegen
herr scholz der herr lindner erwarten
wir erwarten vor allem die pendler die
familien die lkw-fahrer all diejenigen
die jeden tag an der zapfsäule zahlen
müssen dass sie hier endlich lösungen
auf den tisch legen dass wir zur
entlastung kommen sie schnell wirksam
sind und einen unterschied machen
die entlastung so schnell wirken
unbürokratisch sein und mindestens 40
cent pro liter ausmachen eine
tankfüllung kostet mittlerweile bei 50
litern unter 10 120 euro wie sollen wir
das alles noch bezahlen diese frage
stellen sich viele menschen im land und
deswegen bitte so schnell wie möglich
denn das wirkt auch sofort die
mehrwertsteuer die mineralöl- oder
energie steuer auf den sprit senken die
sanktionen sollen putin und seine
oligarchen treffen und nicht die pendler
und deswegen braucht es hier deutliche
entlastung
wenn es dann heißt und jetzt werden sie
können gern weiter sprechen tun das aber
auf kosten ihrer kollegen kommen ja auch
schon zum schluss frau präsidentin
vielen dank wenn es dann heißt das dass
in brüssel schwer wäre ja das mag sein
man muss sich dann in brüssel einsetzen
für dieses thema andere länder in europa
tun dass auch diese erwartungen haben
wir auch an die bundesregierung und
deswegen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
brauchen wir eine putin freie
energieversorgung dafür einen plan der
bundesregierung wie das gelingen soll
wir brauchen eine technologieoffene
ideologiefreie prüfung aller optionen
aber vor allem haben es die familien
pendler verdient dass die spritpreise
endlich sinken tun sie was
und das sagt ihr einsparen der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
unionsfraktion zum antrag aus der
unionsfraktion der sich beschäftigten
mit einer sicheren und bezahlbaren
energieversorgung
putin frei müsse man werden hat er zu
beginn gesagt und eine
laufzeitverlängerung der akw noch nicht
ganz abgeschrieben und die ja sagt er
manche entscheidung und damit meint er
beispielsweise nord stream 2 die würde
man heute wahrscheinlich anders dreßen
nina scheer ist die nächste rednerin
klima und energiepolitische sprecherin
der spd-fraktion
russlands auf die ukraine schärfste zu
verurteilen das möchte ich noch mal hier
ganz klar betonen und ich danke auch
präsident zielinsky für seine heute an
uns gerichteten worte es gibt keine
mauer es gibt solidarität und hilfe es
gibt das gemeinsame ziel des friedens
auch wenn der weg dahin noch gefunden
werden muss und nicht in allen fragen
der umsetzbarkeit für eben diesen
frieden übereinstimmung geblieben ist
ich begrüße ausdrücklich dass die
bundesregierung trotz dieser
völkerrechtlich eindeutigen lage alles
versucht um auch auf dem diplomatischen
weg weiterhin darauf hinzuwirken dass
der krieg schnellstmöglich beendet
der krieg
hat auch eine energiepolitische
dimension wenn unser land zu 55 prozent
abhängig von gasimporten aus russland
ist und von russland nun in europa
kriegt es geht verdeutlicht dies in
drastischer weise welche gefahr im top
abhängigkeiten darstellen dies gilt erst
recht wenn es um energie rohstoffe und
damit letztlich um fragen der
daseinsvorsorge gibt
eine ware kommt gleichwohl angesichts
der hiermit verbundenen folgewirkungen
nicht in betracht umso mehr muss die
abhängigkeit von fossilen ressourcen und
übrigens auch ohne einen krieg durch den
beschleunigten umstieg auf erneuerbare
energien beendet
ist dieser reicht das müssen die
bezugsrechte importe aufgeteilt und
beziehungsweise diversifiziert werden an
beiden wird unter hochdruck gearbeitet
wichtig ist dass dies nun die dass die
nun zu verkraften maßnahmen zugleich den
beschleunigten umstieg auf erneuerbare
energien dienen sind auch lng terminals
können nur dann diesen weg dienen wenn
sie zugleich wasserstoff anlandung
ermöglichen
alles andere wäre sowohl im kampf gegen
den klimawandel als auch zur loslösung
von endlichen fossilen ressourcen nicht
verantwortbar in diesem sinne wie auch
aus weiteren gründen sind die mit dem
vorliegenden antrag von cdu csu
offenkundig verfolgten
laufzeitverlängerung für atomkraftwerke
klar abzulehnen
atomenergie ist schwer regelbar
risikobehaftet die teuerste form der
energiegewinnung und erschwert mit ihrer
unflexibilität einen weiteren aufwuchs
erneuerbare energien sie arbeiten sparen
sie haben es ja angesprochen was sie
hier programmatisch verfolgen sie
arbeiten sich an unserem
koalitionsvertrag somit als wieder was
nicht umgesetzt
und die von ihnen vorgeschlagene
absenkung der eeg umlage sie haben sogar
sortiert da sie das mitte februar
erwähnt hätten das haben wir schon
längst im januar auf den weg gebracht
also der schuh wird anders und doch die
aussagen des antrags zu beschleunigten
energiewende sind zudem höchst
widersprüchlich wenn sie offenkundig ein
problem mit windenergie an land haben
herr sparen sie übrigens in ihrer rede
kein einziges mal war mal das wort
erneuerbare energien in den mund
genommen das finde ich sehr bezeichnet
das ist ihre aussage zum turbo wert den
sie bei den erneuerbaren energien
anzünden wollen wenn sie dann noch
zuvor die akzeptanz frage zitat geklärt
haben wollen zudem mit dem zitat damit
die einbeziehung der belange der
anwohner ja das ist auch wieder zum
schlagwort heißt denn das bitte schön
hunderttausende anwohnerinnen und
anwohner leiden unter
atemwegserkrankungen unter stickoxiden
und anderen schadstoffen im zusammenhang
mit der verbrennung fossiler ressourcen
stehen sie machen hier wieder ein kampf
fällt auf windenergie ist keine
bedrohung sondern die tragende säule der
energiewende in der erneuerbare energien
bringen freiheit weg von abhängigkeit
lassen sie endlich die ca
abstandsregelungen in bayern fallen wir
brauchen die perspektive auf die
heimische wertschöpfung mit wochenend
unabhängigkeit und möglichkeiten der
begrenzung des klimawandels wir brauchen
keine verhinderungs gesetze machen sie
bitte bei ihnen zu hause ihre
hausaufgaben wenn es souveränität in die
überschrift ihres antrages schafft in
bezug auf energie dann lösen sie doch
bitte endlich diese eklatanten
widersprüche auf es geht bei allem aber
auch um energie sicherheit wenn etwa
nordex seine rotorblattproduktion in
rostock schließt um sie ins ausland zu
verlegen ist dies längst keine reine
unternehmensentscheidungen werden nein
es geht hier um den verlust von
zukunftsweisenden arbeitsplätze und um
energiesicherheit
im zweifel hat in solchen fragen meines
erachtens der staat auch eine
garantenstellung gleiches gilt etwa zur
sicherung von gasspeichern und auch
deren füllstände heute abend wird das im
bundestag hier noch debattiert unter
einbeziehung unseres bundesministers
übrigens falls hier diese angriffe noch
mal kommen sollten mit einer reihe
bereits auf den weg gebrachten maßnahmen
werden mit der ampel koalition umfassend
energiewende hemmnisse beseitigt die
seit dem letzten jahr
starb marktgetriebenen verteuerung der
fossilen energie es ist übrigens eine
reine fossile energie krise er hat
bereits vor dem völkerrechtswidrigen
angriff auf russland als auch die
ukraine zu sozialen preisen geführt
daher wurden richtigerweise schnell
entlastungen beschlossen so mit dem
inzwischen sogar verdoppelten
heizkostenzuschuss oft nunmehr 270 euro
aber auch mit der zur jahresmitte
bevorstehende absenkung der eeg umlage
auf null die heute in den bundestag
eingebracht wird über weitere entlastung
wird verhandelt
hierbei ist festzuhalten die
preissteigerungen basieren heute nicht
auf tatsächlicher verknappung sondern
auch erwartungen es ist somit auch
unsere aufgabe spekulationen einen
wirksamen riegel vorzuschieben
die notwendigkeit der beschleunigten
umstieg auf erneuerbare energien sollte
als erkenntnis die chance begriffen
werden völkerverständigung die weltweite
abhängigkeit einer wachsenden
bevölkerung von immer weniger werdenden
fossilen ressourcen zu überwinden im
sinne von freiheit und frieden ihr
antrag hängt in allen sinnvollen punkten
dem handel der regierungskoalition
hinterher und wird uns auch aus diesem
punkt im wege da sofort abstimmung
abgelehnt vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
nina schon war das klima und
energiepolitische sprecherin der
spd-fraktion wir sind hier im deutschen
bundestag bei der befassung mit einem
antrag aus der unionsfraktion in dem es
um die energieversorgung geht sicher
soll sie sein bezahlbar soll sie sein
sagt die unsere und hat dafür die lassen
und dann den vorschlag gemacht und zu
diesen vorschlägen äußert sich jetzt
kasten hilse aus der alten fraktion wo
er sprecher für klimaschutz und energie
ist frau präsidentin meine damen und
herren liebe landsleute wäre es nicht so
traurig dann könnte man darüber lachen
jetzt da die elementare versorgung der
bevölkerung auch und insbesondere mit
bezahlbarer energie aufs höchste
gefährdet ist kommt sogar die
unionsfraktionen mit einem antrag um die
ecke den sie in der vorankündigung
hochtrabend zeitenwende in der
energiepolitik nannten die zeitenwende
in der energiepolitik sie nannten sie
nur energiewende führt der letztendlich
zu den höchsten strompreise in der welt
und hatte während 16 jahre merkel
allerhöchste priorität in der politik
der cdu aber genau andersherum als sie
sich heute gerieren energie sollte muss
man unbedingt teurer ihre verfügbarkeit
drastisch reduziert werden das war
erklärtes ziel ihrer fraktion natürlich
tatkräftig
angefeuert durch die restlichen
altparteien die opportunisten und vor
allem die grünen kommunisten die wir in
der zwischenzeit in allen fraktionen
außer der afd finden und dafür wurden
diverse maßnahmen getroffen von der
abschaltung der kern kohlekraftwerke der
aufgabe von braunkohletagebauen bis hin
zur effektiven verhinderung der
gewinnung von erdgas aus ertragreichen
deutschen feldern stets flankiert von
energiegewinnung verhinderungs maßnahmen
mittels diverser steuern auf die noch
verfügbaren energieträger will bis hin
zu deren verbot ihr ziel war es
eindeutig zug und zug die energie gas
kohle benzin und strom stark zu
verteuern um den verbrauch drastisch
abzusenken alles natürlich wie immer
begründet mit der hypothese dass die
menschen gemachten co2 emissionen das
klima maßgeblich beeinflussen wofür es
nach wie vor keinen einzigen
wissenschaftlichen beweis gibt tausende
wissenschafter weltweit widersprechen
dieser zur religion erhobenen
behauptungen fakt ist sie wollten von
anfang an die zeitenwende sie nannten
sie nur anders nämlich zunächst große
transformation und dann im herzlichen
einvernehmen mit dem world economic
forum und klaus schwab the great preset
durch den krieg in der ukraine wird nun
offenkundig dass ihre tagträumereien wie
seifenblasen zerplatzen in der physik
und in der politik geht es eben nicht
darum was man sich wünscht sondern um
realitäten die realität ist dass ein
industrieland wie deutschland nicht mit
wind und sonne sicher mit strom versorgt
werden kann
deswegen folgendes zitat mit genehmigung
der präsidentin der bundestag fordert
die bundesregierung auf offen und ohne
vorfestlegungen und im hinblick auf alle
gegebenen rechtlichen technischen und
betriebswirtschaftlichen möglichkeiten
umfassend zu prüfen ob und wie der
weiterbetrieb von kernkraftwerken
zunächst im strecke trieb zur co2 armen
und sicheren stromversorgung in den
kommenden jahren beitragen kann eine
solche prüfung darf anders als der
prüfer merkt des bundesministerium für
wirtschaft und klima sowie des
bundesministeriums für umwelt
naturschutz nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz keine politische
auftragsarbeit seien bei der das
ergebnis der von dem einen grünen
minister angekündigten prüfung schon vor
deren beginn von der anderen grüne
ministerin verkündet wird jetzt müsste
eigentlich beifall von den rängen der
union kommen denn das wort für wort aus
ihren antrag dieser forderung schließen
wir uns natürlich an wobei wir die
sofortige verlängerung der laufzeiten
der letzten drei kernkraftwerke ergänzt
durch die wieder inbetriebnahme der am
jahresanfang stillgelegten kkw es als
dringend erforderlich ansehen
zusätzlich lassen sich unsere
derzeitigen probleme mit wesentlichen
und vor allem sehr schnell entschärfen
wenn sie der klima religion abschwört
innen und zum beispiel unseren antrag
vom zehnten elften
2021 mit der drucksache nummer 20 34
zustimmten in diesem antrag fordern wir
unter anderem den betrieb von
kohlekraftwerken die dem stand der
technik entsprechen uneingeschränkt zu
ermöglichen und sämtliche bemühungen zum
ausstieg aus dieser technik zu
hinterlassen bzw zu beenden und zur
sicherung der elektrizitätsversorgung
auf die landesregierungen einzuwirken
notfalls sofort per erlass durch die
bundesregierung eine provisorische
laufzeitverlängerung für die noch in
betrieb befindlichen noch
betriebsbereiten kohlekraftwerke und
wenn sie wirklich die absicht hätten die
notlage zu beenden zumindest auf
mittlere sicht den preisanstieg zu
dämpfen dann könnten sie mit uns die
voraussetzung für die förderung
heimischen erdgases zum beispiel und
schiefer bestellen und kohleflözen
schaffen deren lagerstätten lagerstätte
in umfang und die gewinnung sind bekannt
was fehlt es allein der politische wille
lieber wollen sie sie alle auch sie herr
gremmels das glas das genau auf die
gleiche art und weise gewonnen wird
übers meer schippern aber was tut man
nicht alles als knallharter lobbyist der
amerikanischen rohstoffindustrie
sowie viele energiepolitiker der
altparteien vorrangig die interessen der
wind und solar brannte amerikanischen
rohstoffindustrie vertreten so dienen
sich viele gesundheitspolitiker der
altparteien bei der pharmaindustrie an
sie wollen gegen viele bedenken
hinsichtlich der fehlenden wirkung der
zu injizieren stoffe deren teilweise
katastrophal nebenwirkung und der
aussage von vielen wissenschaftlern und
juristin dass eine impfpflicht unter den
gegebenen umständen
verfassungswidrig sei eine allgemeine
impfpflicht beschließen selbst und als
ich das las schnürte es mir das herz
zusammen schwangere ab dem vierten monat
sollen sich unter umständen gegen ihren
eigenen willen und natürlich ohne den
noch nicht artikulieren willen des noch
nicht geborenen erdenbürgers einen stoff
infizieren lassen dessen nebenwirkungen
noch nicht umfassend bekannt sind und
das obwohl mehrere studien zb das
großbritannien zeigen dass viel geboten
und rot geworden weil gebärenden den
diese stoffe indiziert wurden um ein
vielfaches höher liegen als es der
normalfall wäre diese menschenverachtung
macht mich fassungslos
ich hoffe dass die armen kinderseelen
sie bis an ihr lebensende und darüber
hinaus verfolgen
ob der antrieb dieser sogenannten
energie und gesundheitspolitiker es gibt
auch weniger ausnahmen muss man hier
sagen nur der schnöde mammon ist oder ob
da mehr dahinter steckt werden wir bald
erfahren
zum wohle des deutschen volkes ist das
handeln dieser korrupten sollte mit dem
karten jedenfalls nicht ich spreche hier
und jetzt die wenigen ausnahmen an
überzeugen sie ihre kollegen den pfad
der zerstörung deutschland zu verlassen
ihre energiewende ist gescheitert sie
war es bereits seit jahren der ukraine
krieg macht dies nur für jedermann
sichtbar leider enthält der hier
vorgelegten antrag jede menge klima
betonte deswegen hier in leider ablehnen
müssen das heißt aber nicht dass wir
nicht in zukunft gemeinsam und zum wohle
unseres volkes konstruktiv an lösungen
arbeiten können ich bedanke mich
vielmals für ihre aufmerksamkeit
der bundestag diskutiert naja jedenfalls
überwiegend über einen antrag der
unionsfraktion zum thema bezahlbare
energieversorgung die union fordert
darin unter anderem von der
bundesregierung dass auch weitere
forderungen der richtige schnell
umzusetzen sind um direkt nach oben dem
aktuellen preisanstieg etwa
entgegenzuwirken und hat dafür
vorschläge gemacht wie wir verlieren ist
die nächste rednerin stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90
16 jahre regierung unter führung von cdu
csu liegen hinter uns das waren
5861 tage
5861 tage hatten sie zeit um deutschland
auf den weg der energiesicherheit den
weg der energie souveränität zu bringen
mit erneuerbaren energien und
energieeffizienz und man muss es so klar
sagen sie haben es gründlich versammelt
sie fordern jetzt entschlossenheit ja in
der tat die hätten wir in den letzten
jahren dringend gebraucht als sie die
mehrheiten hatten doch das gegenteil von
entschlossenheit nämlich die ideologie
und die freundlichkeit von union haben
uns erst in diese aktuelle misere
gebracht sehr teure sehr teure fossile
energie und eine geopolitisch hoch
problematische abhängigkeit ist ihr
verdienst liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der cdu und csu der schreckliche
angriffskrieg und seine konsequenzen für
die menschen in der ukraine und für die
europäische energieversorgung führt uns
die fehler der vergangenheit deutlich
vor augen wenn es schon in den letzten
jahren konsequent versäumt wurde müssen
wir nun jetzt umso schneller unabhängig
werden von den fossilen energieträgern
und
dazu sagen sie ersparen in ihrer rede
nichts auch auf den ersten seiten ihres
antrags nichts dazu erst nachdem sie
noch einmal den umweg durch die
sackgasse atomkraft genommen haben kommt
auf punkt
16.16 kommt in ihrem antrag dann endlich
der entscheidende game changer nämlich
demnach soll die bundesregierung jetzt
endlich mal beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
den turbo anzünden halleluja dass sich
das bei der union noch erleben darf
glauben sie mir dafür brauchen wir eine
aufforderung der union
wir freuen uns natürlich sind sie
ankündigen das was wir jetzt an
wichtigen gesetzen auf den weg bringen
zu unterstützen vielleicht helfen sie
uns auch noch weitere dinge auf den weg
zu bringen ich freue mich drauf ich
möchte sie aber daran erinnern dass
unter unionsgeführte regierung die
solarindustrie aus dem land getrieben
wurde das bei der windenergie die
historisch niedrigsten ausbauzahlen seit
der einführung des eeg es erzielt worden
sind und durch sie zu verantworten sind
ihre politik hat den erneuerbaren
standort in deutschland entfernt
und diese neue bundesregierung dies
jetzt seit 100 tagen im amt seit 100
tagen sein morgen morgen seit 100 tagen
und sie startet mit einer sie startet in
einer massiven energiepreis krise in der
wir stecken mit miss bisher nicht
dagewesenen preisen für gas und kohle
und wir sind daran die schuld aber wie
reagieren schnell und entschlossen auf
diese akute krise die aus der
abhängigkeit von fossilen energien
entstanden ist und zwar handeln wir mit
kurzfristigen hilfen und mit einer
klaren politischen linie ich bin froh
dass der wirtschaftsminister angekündigt
hat und den kartellbehörden
die kartellbehörden aufgefordert hat
klar zu klären ob die absprachen von den
konzernen dafür verantwortlich sind dass
die preise an den tankstellen zu hoch
sind und schon in dieser woche bringen
wir gesetzentwürfe auf den weg um die
bürger bei den energiekosten zu
entlasten
wir schaffen die eeg umlage ab darüber
reden wir heute noch für gewährte einen
heizkostenzuschuss auch den beschließen
wir heute für bedürftige haushalte und
wir schaffen auch ein sofort zuschlag
für kinder das sind maßnahmen die die
menschen jetzt dringend braucht und die
werden heute auf den weg gebracht
gleichzeitig beschleunigen die hetze
umstieg auf erneuerbare energien robert
habeck hat in einem rekordtempo ein
gesetzentwurf zur entfesselung der
erneuerbaren energien vorgelegt das ist
der weitestgehende entwurf den wir
jemals gesehen haben und damit
beschleunigen wir jetzt insbesondere den
ausbau von wind- und solarenergie mit
der perspektive eines klimaneutralen
strom systems bis zum jahr 2035
natürlich können wir nicht alle
versäumnisse aus vielen jahren
rückwärtsgewandte politik
einem schlag auflösen deshalb wird nach
dem muster paket das sommer paket freuen
die reform des strommarkts steht ein
kohleausstieg bis 2030 der aufbau einer
wasserstoffwirtschaft aber ich sage
diese regierung hat in den ersten 100
tagen mehr angeschoben als so manche
vorgängerregierung in einer ganzen
legislaturperiode
ersparen ersparen wir wir wollen alles
alles wollen wir dafür tun damit die
russischen energieimporte so schnell wie
möglich überflüssig werden wir tun
deswegen alles für einen schnelleren
ausbau der erneuerbaren und trotzdem
geht das nicht mit einem fingerschnippen
und der joker der joker der energie
souveränität ist die energieeffizienz
wir müssen und wir können massiv den
energieverbrauch reduzieren
auch dazu in ihrer rede kein wort herr
sparen die energieeffizienz pro fan siwe
hilft uns auch bei der reduzierung der
laufenden kosten denn entscheidend ist
doch dass wir dauerhaft dass wir
dauerhaft von hohen energiekosten
wegkommen das geht nicht über ständig
neue subventionen für den verbrauch von
fossiler energie das wäre ein fass ohne
boden und spielt zusätzlich noch mehr
geld in putins kriegskasse der weg zu
dauerhaft verlässlichen energiepreisen
geht nur über konsequente
zukunftsinvestitionen in
energieeffiziente technik in sparsame
fahrzeuge und verbrauchsarme gebäude es
nützt den mieterinnen doch am wenigsten
wenn sie einfach immer nur geld in die
fossilen konzerne überweisen sie
brauchen wohnungen die so gut gedämmt
sein dass sie auf dauer nur noch die
hälfte der energie zum heizen benötigen
dafür brauchen wir jetzt ersparen wir
brauchen jetzt rekordinvestitionen für
besseres wohnen und faire wärme mit
unserer neuer barren und energie spar
offensive arbeiten wir als ampel am
klimaschutz und sichern eine souveräne
energieversorgung wie ernst es ihnen
damit ist ihnen wohl eher union das
können sie in den kommenden wochen und
monaten beweisen hier im bundestag und
dem bundesrat nach 16 jahren
investitionsbremse der union können sie
jetzt helfen den investitions turbo
anzuschalten ich hoffe sie sind dabei
ich bin sehr dankbar dass wir eine
ampelkoalition hier für den gemeinsamen
willen haben und ich sage in ihrem
parlament wenn wir dafür alles geben
vielen dank die japan stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen sieht in den vergangenen 16
jahren einen
übersichtlichen ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien in dieser zeit und geld
forderungen aus der union für eine turbo
ausbau jetzt wendung für
unangemessen die parlaments
vizepräsidentin petra pau bietet noch
mal nach fast schon flehentlich die
abgeordneten um einhaltung der redezeit
der hintergrund ist dass petra pau und
katrin göring eckardt sich heute die
parlamentssitzung und auch morgen teilen
müssen alle ein land krank sind und dass
mich übernehmen können jetzt ist diesen
lötlampe stellvertretende vorsitzende
der linksfraktion die partei hat ja
heute ein präsident ist eine menge
nach zehn langen regierungsjahren legen
cdu und csu einen umfangreichen
forderungskatalog vor ohne ein wort
wirklicher selbstkritik und ohne darüber
zu sprechen dass sie den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien effektiv und aktiv
behindert haben und das ist nicht in
ordnung eine damen und herren und ohne
darüber zu sprechen dass unter ihrer
verantwortung die öffentliche
infrastruktur zerfallen ist allein auf
der ebene der kommunen müssten schon
längst 150 milliarden euro investiert
worden seien und sie sagen in ihrem
antrag auch überhaupt nichts zur
finanzierung und ich kann ihnen auch
erklären warum sie das nicht tun denn
sie wollen weiter an der schwarzen null
und an der schuldenbremse festhalten
sie wollen steuererhöhungen für
vermögende verhindert und ich kann ihnen
sagen wir wollen das nicht wir wollen
endlich gerechte steuern und herren und
sie unterstützen das 100 milliarden auf
rüstungs paket der bundesregierung und
auch das ist falsch
bundes
energieminister robert habeck sagt den
menschen wechselt doch einfach dem
stromanbieter wenn es euch zu teuer ist
das zeigt kollege habe ich von
erschreckender unkenntnis die ärmsten in
unserer gesellschaft zahlen die höchsten
strompreise denn sie können gar keinen
strom tarif wählen sie müssen den tarif
nehmen denen ihnen der grundversorger
anbietet und auf ihrer internetseite
schreiben sie von rahmenbedingungen und
markttransparenz das ist kann ich ihnen
sagen wirklich marktliberaler uns in
meine damen und herren die eu kommission
ist im vergleich zu ihnen geradezu
revolutionär im strategiepapier der eu
steht regierungen dürfen in solchen
ausnahmesituationen
energiepreise für die verbraucher
festsetzen und ich frage mich warum
macht das die bundesregierung nicht und
es ist auch möglich so die eu kommission
weiter gewinne bei den energieversorgern
abzuschätzen die gerade prächtig
verdienen er habe ich an der stelle
müssten sie doch mal endlich beherzt
eingreifen das ist das gebot der stunde
oder orientieren als mal in anderen
ländern schauen wir nach griechenland
der premierminister ein christdemokrat
kollege sparen will massiv in die
großhandelsmärkte für energie eingreifen
er will den gaspreis auf vorkrisenniveau
deckeln eine höchstgrenze für tägliche
preisschwankungen einführen und die
gewinnmarge der stromversorger begrenzen
und spekulativen handel verbieten daran
könnte man sich orientieren meint tag
jetzt kommen nicht zur fdp herr lindner
der ja den eindruck erweckt er wäre der
eigentliche chef hier in der
bundesregierung will einen tank rabatt
warum fordern sie eigentlich keinen
mieten rabatt und keinen rabatt für
öffentliche verkehrsmittel das wäre der
richtige weg meine damen und herren
und es ist auch völlig klar wer heute
gerade von der energie krise profitiert
es sind die
ölraffinerien und den müssen die
krisengewinner wirklich weg gesteuert
werden dass wir eine politische aufgabe
mein name terra
wir haben heute
zu anfang der sitzung eine sehr
beeindruckende rede gehört und ich kann
für meine fraktion noch mal ganz
deutlich sagen wir wollen alles tun mit
allen menschen gemeinsam die für den
frieden einstehen dass der krieg gegen
die ukraine endlich beendet wird alle
menschen haben ein recht darauf in
frieden zu leben und auch wir sind
verantwortlich dafür dieses recht mit zu
garantieren und darum kann ich nur sagen
endlich die waffen nieder
[Applaus]
das wort der kollege michael kruse für
die fdp-fraktion
michael kruse ist energiepolitischer
sprecher seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zunächst eine
gewisse sprachlosigkeit hiernach der
nach der video botschaft macht mich
sprachlos und ich bedauere dass wir es
im parlament angesichts dieser
historischen rede nicht geschafft haben
das unsere unterstützung in worte zu
fassen präsident selensky hat sehr
treffend formuliert dass
die wirtschaftspolitik des westens als
ein sehr wesentliches instrument ansieht
und wir reden ja heute im bereich der
energiepolitik vor allem darüber welche
macht wir haben um entscheidungen anders
zu treffen ich zitiere in präsident
seeländer sagte wirtschaft wirtschaft
wirtschaft es dürfe nicht alles sein es
dürfe nicht das entscheidende kriterium
seines dürfe nicht das einzige kriterium
sein und in der tat unsere
wirtschaftspolitik muss in diesen zeiten
freiheits politik sein unsere
wirtschafts und energiepolitik sie muss
friedenspolitik werden und deswegen bin
ich dem bundesfinanzminister auch sehr
dankbar dass er an dieser stelle im
rahmen der aussprache zur
regierungserklärung klar formuliert hat
das erneuerbare energien freiheits
energien sind meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren
und die jetzige bundesregierung die
regierung hat in den letzten wochen sehr
viel getan zum thema
versorgungssicherheit zum thema
schaffung von energiesicherheit und
es nötigt mir persönlich großen respekt
ab dass ein grüner wirtschaftsminister
der erste grüne wirtschaftsminister
an das tabu herangeht seiner partei und
sagt nicht mal das länger laufen lassen
der kernkraftwerke ist mehr ein
diesen respekt könnten sie der minister
ja auch entgegenbringen und
die tatsache dass dann eine prüfung
erfolgt an deren ende steht
frau kollegin klöckner das war etwas
später nachdem die analyse erfolgt es da
hat er das ausgeschlossen das stimmt die
tatsache dass am ende dieser analysen
allerdings steht dass auch hier die
letzte regierung die große koalition mit
einem wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
dafür gesorgt hat dass wesentliche
sicherheitsüberprüfung ausgesetzt werden
im jahr 2019 die zehnjährige
sicherheitsüberprüfung die angestanden
hätte nicht mehr hat stattfinden müssen
führt dazu dass diese kraftwerke
mittlerweile ein großes und jeden tag
größeres sicherheitsrisiko darstellen
und deswegen muss man am ende dieser
analyse doch feststellen das ist sehr
klug dass den weg zu gehen den die
regierung jetzt geht um hier energie
sicherheit herbeizuführen nämlich all
diejenigen kraftwerke mit ressourcen zu
versorgen die die stabilität im netz
garantieren können auch wenn wir zum
beispiel mal eine dunkel flaute haben
und deswegen lade ich sie hier die
analyse mal zu lesen und dann auch zum
richtigen schluss zu kommen denn sie
zeigt wir hier alle im raum wir wären
verantwortlich dafür dass diese
kernkraftwerke jeden tag unsicherer
werden wir während dafür verantwortlich
im event fall zu erklären warum das denn
unbedingt hat stattfinden müssen und
wenn sie verantwortung bereit sind dafür
zu übernehmen schön und gut die mehrheit
in diesem hause ist es nicht und ich
persönlich nicht wehren konnte
herr kollege sparen sie haben hier ihren
antrag vorgestellt und ich fand das sehr
sehr gute weiterentwicklung zu unserer
letzten debatte die etwas hitziger war
vielleicht auch der ernsthaftigkeit des
themas nicht an jeder stelle angemessen
ich war das im stil besser ich fand das
auch vom inhalt besser was wir hier
heute vorgelegt haben und das insgesamt
finde ich für die ernsthaftigkeit dieser
debatte begrüßen es werden unsere
bestandsaufnahme morgen sind die 100
tage für die ampel regierung um unsere
bestandsaufnahme zu ihrer broker zeit
ihrer groko arbeit kann ich ihnen
allerdings nicht ersparen denn sie ist
eine wesentliche basis warum wir heute
darüber diskutieren
in einem nachtwächter staat darf der